a presentation a welcome to visitors and
residents and I
for
um at least 30 plus
the Landscaping budget who wanted to put
additional money in
this this to me is of priority I think
particularly for kaiapoi I know rangiora
has done quite a good job
um over the the years and I um I don't
know that
that this the Assyrian argument here
that we accelerate and deal to
the entrances
um particularly to The District in
kaiapoi so I would urge that um you do
support this and the strategy that has
was a long time in the making needs
clearly needs review now and it actually
needs money and resource put to it in my
view thank you encourage you it's the
question of our finance stuff what would
they add to their budget please
um
well I clarified it at 30 000. I did
with Council Duty
with that one so
so so well I've allowed the I mean mint
because it's with an order but it's up
to members to decide whether it's
appropriate or not the other way of
dealing with it is to call for a staff
report is has been suggested
um uh Kathy Atkinson thank you Mr
question because I'm a little confused
now because what's uh what councilor
Stewart has asked for is my in my view
of Maintenance budget
Council of Duty is asking for as a
budget to increase to put into the
increase of doing entrance signs
for the district I'm confused now what
we're looking at because
um if it is a maintenance budget then
this is the wrong area to be putting
thirty thousand dollars in for that if
it's actually to produce signs then
that's an increase of thirty thousand so
on and and I think I take on board what
Jeff's saying about I just can clarify
please it's can you read back what the
recommendation sorry about the um
interest budgets across the district
well I can probably provide a little bit
of clarity to Mr Atkinson though
the two reserves which councilor short
were referring to
um need capital investment
um the one the lake which is referred to
has capital investment identified in the
long-term plan already the other one is
actually the um referred to in the next
submission that we're going to get to on
the next page but it is capital
investment as opposed to maintenance the
lack of maintenance is
um and those areas um well there's never
been any maintenance in those areas so
it isn't just to maintenance budget it's
capital budget and
um yeah okay sorry I've confused my two
questions and one was exactly that
around Capital but is there any further
maintenance budget for both those two
areas because we wasted time spending
Capital money if you've got no going
forward maintenance to look after it yes
there is within the um long-term plan
budget at the moment uh no just for the
lake area which has got Capital funding
in it because there is no Capital
funding a long-term plan for the Gary
across the road from hellers at the
moment and I understood you said that
there was no Capital funding in there
for Town entrance signage there is no
budget at the moment um for
um Town entrance enhancement and the
strategy which has provided identified
an amount of 50 as being a relevant
amount for each year to work through
what was identified so she's on the
table at the present time Council
Barnett I'm not I'm not going to get
into a Dutch auction about it either so
I'm just saying I'm clear we're all
clear what it's for whether it succeeds
or not as a matter for debate well not
only debate but vote shortly
while I have some sympathy for the
intention of the amendment I'm not going
to vote for it and the reason is that I
think we need a wider investigation
actually I think the reasons for that
come into number 48 with the officer on
page 48 with the officer recommendations
where it took some of the difference
between the boards and what funding they
have available and what funding they've
spent and I think this area needs a
complete review Oxford hocus struggles
to provide any extra funding except for
small landscaping and we may need to
look at that completely separately
um I know that wooden doesn't have a
proper entrance sign it's on State
Highway One it has a Lions Club one but
you know there's a lot more work to be
done on this and that's why we need a
report it may be that we need some more
physical to make sure capital investment
in later years but I think we've lost
sight of of the original plan we need to
revisit it we need to review how fair it
is to allow
awards that have smaller populations and
large areas particularly whether they
can fund it was pumped a lot of money or
from their fund into earthquake
regeneration so therefore they haven't
had the money to spend on the entrance
signs it's been a lower priority so I
actually think it's something we need to
just review as a whole Council we do
need some way of saying that Welcome to
our town and kaiapoi to me and woodend
and some of the and some of the areas in
the the outer District do need some some
looking at cust has a lovely entrance
sign but that was from a project that
was done individually at a Casper's
Vision Cafe I'd like to see the holistic
picture and I'd like to see how much it
would cost before we move any other
funds okay uh Council Redmond oh sorry
Council Williams first
okay that's fine you can signal it yep
um but can I just get the question first
from Council is a question are you
speaking to it
yeah oh hold on I'll take a bit of take
the amendment first so yep I'd like to
move the movement amendment that we
require request
we'll ask for a report
for a report to come forward with a
review
of the entranceways including
maintenance follow-up on these areas
with a maintenance Budget on on the
capital that was spent
okay seconded by Council Williams Okay
so
speak to your Amendment well I don't
think I need to speak to it I think
councilor Barnett's actually since
you've moved what she was talking about
I think we'd have the that I think that
explained it well I think we do need one
speaker at a time please thank you we do
need a review and we do need the report
to come back because Jeff's absolutely
right I mean normally we would get a
report on these things before we just
add money and I think that is the proper
way to go about it
okay to speak to you yeah
um I was originally gonna
sort of um original thoughts was on this
line was Council Barnett was saying I
know the rangiora community board
um we've been quite Frugal on their
budget saving money towards the entrance
ways
and
um
so you know the report from fairness for
all the community Awards is the way to
go Council Redmond
uh thank you Mr Mayor I'm pleased to
support the amendment I was going to
oppose the earlier Amendment
um the the thing that occurs to me is
the entrance way is more than a sign it
is the whole area as I think councilor
Stewart mentioned and I am aware that
the Esplanade area opposite hammers
which is really a disgrace was
previously maintained by an adjoining
landowner at no cost to the council as
far as I'm aware
um
I also think that
it's really up to the community boards I
think to choose and be involved in the
process I don't really think it's for us
at the ltp to suddenly be introducing uh
rules for entrance ways so anyhow I'm
happy to support a report and I will be
voting in favor yep so Council blicky
did I also got the amendment 30k
throwing into this pool is peanuts it
wouldn't achieve anything I recall from
that strategy first came up
um there's something like 15 inference
ways to our various towns and Villages
and in the area too it's a it's for
instance kaiapo he hasn't got two
entrances it's got four so we need to go
back in and reassess the whole thing
okay uh cancer meetings
just in addition to comments already
made
in this report it says rather in the
officer's recommendations it's it talks
about money that's been allocated and
money that's been spent
um we and it also points out that the
October Hoka community board haven't
allocated any yet because they do have
that smaller Landscaping fund and so I
very much support the amendment in in a
whole review of of this we have a
strategy right now with no funding and
behind it which is well frankly quite
useless so we need to get onto that and
have a have a better look at it
and I'm I'm also going to support the
amendment it makes sense to have a um a
whole a complete look at it including
our discretionary budget conversation
that we had before it should be holistic
at the moment it has been over the years
a bit piecemeal and here it's been
considered there was a good policy some
years ago we were sitting aside
for memory around fifty thousand per
annum and progressively we were then
able to upgrade signage so we dealt with
the town signage entrances and cust and
other locations
colleagues are quite welcome to put
forward amendments through this there's
there's nothing wrong on what's been
proposed here at all um but it would it
be more prudent to call for report use
but there's nothing stopping anyone from
putting an amendment I just want to make
that clear and I'll entertain it as we
go through because we have submission
points and as long as there's a
submission Point linked to it there's no
problem in doing so fear the speakers to
the amendment
well can we just we just
okay well you can vote for the amendment
how's that because otherwise I'm going
to get into a Miss
yep hold on not normally no
um all right yeah
I'm going to put the um do you wish to
speak to me inventory review no I'm
going to put the amendment uh all those
in favor please say aye country
the key that carries the amendment
becomes the motion
um
I don't think we need to speak further
about that and these people you can
speak to the main motion again if you
wish councilor briefly actually spoken
very very religiously I just well it is
briefly but it's actually important
because we're just asking for another
report and our staff are under
incredible amount of pressure so
um I'd like to see um come back to us
some timelines around some realistic
timelines around what we're asking for
because I'm very aware of pressures on
on our staff
um right at the moment so if we could
get maybe the timeline first of when we
can expect that so there's no so we
don't have huge high expectations of uh
of our staff getting that report there
so very it's a very fair comment and if
you're the speakers
write a reply if you wish Council Duty
no
you don't have to no and I will do
um the original when I originally chose
this to put out thirty thousand and it
was to keep it simple
it's in the keep it simple people
communities that wanted to apply for it
had the right to put their name forward
to do something for their community and
that's really where that's why keep it
Simplicity I'm not going to have any
further debate there's no physical
procedure no need to raise
um we should have voted on voted or
withdrawn the First Amendment before we
went to the Second Amendment we can't no
well no it's entirely appropriate
well I don't look I'm I'm not going to
rule it's fine so
um can we now uh it's become the motion
so all those in favor please say aye
country I declare that carried
you're against
okay so counselors against uh they're
all right
moving forward page 49
page 50. so just on this here uh 51 this
is
can you just give me a second sorry so
just to be clear page 51 is the 17
thousands included in the white sheet
that Jeff gave us this morning is that
correct
that's what I've seen here yes I would
just like to I'm really happy and for
them to get there um their uh barbecue
but in their submission we did recommend
that maybe
um they had ten thousand dollars for a
pagoda and two and a half thousand
dollars for a table and we did suggest
that they maybe approach their local
lions or the men's shed to see if they
could put those together for them your
question is my question is is that
possible have they have they approached
um that sort of
um
taking that approach to see if they can
get that funding elsewhere just cheaper
starfish and then if that's not adequate
then you can answer cancel duties
the group has already raised seventeen
thousand dollars of their own towards
the barbecue which is um what's being
requested additional funding for that so
they've done a huge amount of work over
the years firstly to to fund the
um the the cottage which was done a
number of years ago and and raise
seventeen thousand dollars I'm here at
the moment
um with those other assets that you've
identified we'd be happy to continue to
work with them on on external funding
for that but it's only the barbecue
which they've requested funding for
specifically here
okay any further questions
you happy with it did you want to eat
something because you're on The Advisory
Group Council Duty
um
close biking with the Lions and they are
going to be working with them they are
they going to be doing a lot of work
themselves as well okay so is there any
um one against what's recommended there
okay moving forward
um so kaiapui River rehabilitation
page 51.
um I need to step aside from this
because it's kind of reality Expo page
52 that's right someone just let me know
when it's um
particularly
1.2
1.273 just just a question sorry
um
is this is event funding doesn't it fall
under
Simon's team doesn't it fall under the
events and promotion rather than under
Green Space
um uh it was part of a wider um
submission which was received by
um the cockatoo who took Highway
community board so it's just been
included it's been put into here because
it seemed to be included in there
they're being under your budget
sometimes a large amount of
um individual submission points so we we
do talk to each other
um regarding the submission responses I
would also note that we've put declines
request for sixty thousand dollars um
they've just requested some funding not
necessarily the 460 but the principle
which we've identified in our reason
Still Remains the Same in terms of grant
funding for events like this so the
words could be changed to declines the
request for funding as opposed to the
sixty thousand dollars specifically you
can do that uh Chris because it wasn't
they didn't ask for sixty thousand
dollars no Mr chair just also um
my understanding of the submission is
all they were asking was instead of
getting 500 from each of the boards to
get one Grant from the council
um so I'd prefer to move an amendment in
that direction that they get two
thousand from them
watch Steve questions so
um to include to include a grant of two
thousand dollars
to the colloquy art expo reducing the
500 grants from the community boards
thank you do we have a second so
um Council of Blackie yeah so it's a
straight swap there's no Ransom
paperwork
right Council yep just speaking to that
um honoring on the Rangers community
board that has been noted by some of the
boards and the board chairs have
discussed this and that it seems silly
that they have to write foreground
applications and come to four different
boards when it's a district event that
benefits the whole district and every
time the boards have accepted that 500
Grant
um at this stage I think it would be
much more sense that we put it into this
year's annual plan I'm not recommending
putting it in annually I'm thinking that
something we will need to discuss at
each point but I think for this
financial year we should put it in as a
2000 as it is the request of the
community boards that it would make
simplify the administration of this
grant
thank you
Council lady
Council of Duty
thank you I think this is a very well
good thing to do because I just find why
the Oxford Ohio community board our
funds never reached the end of their
potential at all because they're always
gobbled up and assisting and the extra
500 would go well in our community
councilor there you go understanding of
the re of the amendment that has been
moved that it reduces
seven th Jersey
it reduces the grants going to the
boards
stops the application
yes okay
yes is everyone aware of the of the of
the amendment that's put forward that it
is to reduce the boards by 500.
to make up this grout
okay
so all right so discretion Council
okay thank you any further debate
I put the amendment all those in favor
against
Council that he was against
Karen
thank you
right we better get the mirror or should
we just carry on
[Laughter]
Hey Brother you've done the whole lot oh
Excellence yeah great I love that
efficiency
okay
and if we can just call that the board's
contribution towards this event as
opposed to councils to avoid
um us setting a precedent in terms of
event funding from Council
um it would be good if this was still
the board's contribution as opposed to
council
sorry that we notified the boards
because we haven't done that in the
effort so
the reason for that is can I just stamps
okay so it's the reason I asked it
because the board is a simple way to
count so you want the race still the
same as if it included it but it's it's
funny
yeah right that's okay okay
right so 50
54.
um
um 50 55 cross side some questions here
um or just some one of some suggestions
with Cooper's Creek um for Mr Jason
Smith's
um
um submission I actually attended I went
out on Saturday with a group of
neighbors to have a look at this
location and what's occurring out here
is you've got people defecating
everywhere and not using the toilets
even the new Doc one is still not being
used so I wondered whether it might be
appropriate that there is a
um some work and by way of a report to
the community board on options including
at Council and community board including
the car park out there
and you just need to work that through
with your work stream it's but it's it's
it's being highly usually used this area
and I think if we could call it for a
report it would be helpful to understand
broadly what's happening out there
know you were happy to do that we'll
have to undertake some Community
consultation with those people who are
next door because there is some
difference in opinion in regards to the
development that from some community
members who who don't want to see more
development which may bring more people
than others who want to see the mess
tidied up at the moment and we'll also
have to have further conversations
Department of Conservation who would
love to see it tidied up however
who pays will be the issue don't want a
significant I do note that
round four of the tourism infrastructure
fund was put back up for application so
um
that might help well be I I just think
it needs a bit more stuff we could do
that that would be really good does
anyone disagree with us calling for
report on that it's really good to by
the way really good to see it being
really well used the ride Falls and that
out there it's a beautiful really
beautiful area Council Duty yeah I do
Wonder perhaps if a little bit more
signage to encourage people to go and
use the correct space yes
pacifier law for common sense
[Laughter]
would have thought that's fairly obvious
but never mind Rado
um so
um we're now on to 56 which is the
public trust and that's been recommended
within the White Pages as well as the of
uh ten thousand dollars per annum
is that correct Chris
yeah double Christie 25 per annum I've
put a seed funding amount of ten
thousand dollar
per year
um
ten thousand dollars will be helpful um
twenty five thousand dollars is probably
more realistic if you actually want to
to build something I'm sure everyone
here will will know how expensive it is
to
um build public art in a public place
um however
um based on the fact that the council
didn't allocate any money originally um
I thought ten thousand dollars was going
to be a more palatable figure and I will
note that the the group um why pet they
have actually
um they're very professional and they
have done a huge amount of work and
setting up themselves as a charitable
trust creating a bank account talking to
um other similar organizations around
the country
um and
um I believe that they will be extremely
successful because of the people on it
and the energy that they do have
um the other is don't we provide some
administrative support as well so we pay
we we do five thousand dollars at the
moment which is um we give secretary
um support
um and then we have funding towards the
auditing of their accounts and my
understanding is they've also received a
000 well an indication of a twenty five
thousand dollar donation towards a piece
of public art is that correct no that's
right yes yeah okay
anyone opposed with that direction
okay so sure yeah we picked the wrong
year to set this thing up
yeah but I think that's a really
positive way forward so thank you
um all right so 57
so I understand if I'm correct as well
that the White Pages pick up the
mandible Sports Club is 10 000 added
here is that correct
and there's a well infrastructure yeah
let's see 28 000 somewhere so it's 28 28
is on on your your um little white piece
of paper that Jeff has provided with
there's also there's two there's ten
thousand dollars identified
um and then there's also the 28 the 28
is for the variable speed pump which is
a piece of infrastructure sorry variable
speed Drive
[Music]
um
probably be starting when it comes in
what that is and what it does um that
one off but that is a one-off piece of
kit that we need to put in to stop sand
getting into the bottom of that well
you're all for those who are around
understand how difficult it was to get
that well in the first place and we need
to do that to actually
um protect that the rest of it is
um for some money towards I believe the
bike track around the perimeter and
we've identified that we've also got
existing budget that we can use to help
them with a bit of um large tree removal
stuff in there as well they've already
done a little bit of that walking and
biking track around the perimeter and
people are using it at the moment it's
part of the implementation of their
concept plan that was created about
eight years ago
so if we're adding 10 then the Rick
sorry then the it was an additional page
that came out wasn't there so in that
wording it talks of
um a second paragraph on the bottom five
thousand per year for next three years
or what's ten thousand so is that right
uh it should be 15.
so you just just change that wording yep
also talks of words like austerity
measures I would personally prefer that
that's not in there
we don't use that terminology
you know maybe in the response of the
submitter
where it says at the top Council
continues something along that greatly
values the work and partnership we have
because that's really what we have with
mandible Sports Club so you can just
pick up there any other
no everyone help you with that
it's wrong
it's a teen isn't it
it's 15 all up so this bit of paper here
which was provided by GF identifies at
the bottom it's 10 that needs to be
changed to 15 to align with three so
what is the 15 for it's pump track
15 or three years and is that is that
for so what is the other five for
um so sorry it's 5 000 per year so
what's reflected in the sheet is only
five thousand for two years so what
we're saying is 5000 for every year of
the ltp so it should be 15.
oh well 21 22 then is five change there
and then the staff will finance staff
will adjust the
um yes that's right so it should only be
five on there yep
yes not seen yeah it's 15 over the three
year period understand right on the
right no no good good Clarity all right
okay everyone happy with that okay so
um
Ice north Canterbury gym Sports
so I I have a question here
um I wondered Chris knows what my
question is going to be because I've
already raised it with them around
potential of of us purchasing Council
purchasing that building and or or
providing a loan
for them because it's in a they're in a
bit of a situation stuck here if it's
not sold then it holds up some other
funding with the sports trust and really
if it's in and out so that they can
appears from what they presented to us
that they can afford to manage a loan if
they can do that then it's not really an
impost on the council as such I just
welcome your reflection on that and how
we might deal with that matter
so at the moment we're doing some
investigation on the building the
building's not up to 67 of the building
code at the moment and we need to
understand what that percentage actually
is and what it would cost to get it up
to to code the the building was being
sold was being offered to ice trampolini
at a reduced rate the trust as you'll
know owe or committed a million dollars
towards the fit out of the stadium and
they were going to use the sale of
Edward Street to fund
um to to fund that for Council if the
council was to look to purchase this
building ice trampolini do run a very
commercial model they're currently
charged I believe around sixty thousand
dollars to use that building at the
moment so they would if we bought the
building depending on the additional
cost to get it up to code they would be
able to pay all of the the holding costs
to that building so the the interest on
the loan in some case through for that
building so it wouldn't cost to cancel
anything necessarily
if there is a delay of course in
um the trust being able to give us that
million dollars we don't have that
million dollars in the budget at the
moment so there'd be an overspend of a
million dollars in that budget
um so that would have to be factored in
as well so
um at the moment I need to wait for that
information to come back from bevich who
are the consultant doing the assessment
um and then I'd be happy to come back to
the council with a report which
identifies
um potential Purchase cost of the
building
um what it would cost to get it up to
standard
um what the interest and capital
payments over time on any loan from the
council would be Etc so when would you
be able to bring a report back to us on
that normal time is of the essence
um needs to be before we pay the final
bill to
um to leads to try and avoid us having
to
um having to Loan Fund an additional
million dollars that we hadn't
anticipated so do you think it's
possible to do that within the next
month I'm hoping so okay
deposit
um is loan funding for the deposit they
could Finance the rest and the banks
have given them that indication
and the reason that I make that
statement will reiterate that statement
they gave is that we're talking about 67
percent of code under our policy their
policy it will be well I don't know
their policy personally but the actual
uh there's 34 of code if we were to Loan
Fund a policy does that put us in the
situation just because we've lent them
the money to get the building
does that put us in the situation where
we have to get it to 67 because I
couldn't see how it would that would
allow them to carry on at 34 code and
get going and carry on doing what
they're doing is my understanding but I
stand to be corrected yeah they
uh yes this that that is an option we
could Loan Fund them the money that the
bank uh no sorry no so so so sorry at
the moment the bank was going to lend
them 65 of the purchase price of the
building and then they were looking to
us to either Grant fund or Loan Fund um
the rest of that
um if the building the the bank is now
aware of the fact that the building's
not up to code and if said they won't
give them the 65 so we would have to
Loan Fund them the whole lot
um and then they would uh because they
can't get the money from the bank
anymore no one will loan them any money
based on a building being below code so
we would have to so so is it the
building is below code
we don't know so I'm not sure so the
bank the bankers the bankers said they
won't loan it unless it is up to 67 so
that's the bank's rules
so so look is anyone opposed to staff
preparing a report to us to come up to
us with options because to be honest
it's a bit of a pickle this situation
um and there's a lot relying on it we've
got the chair of the trust chasing me
for a response about what our response
might be because he's got a trust
meeting on Thursday and they're really
nervous because they don't want to leave
us down and the commitments they've
given so I think a report on this as
soon as possible would be the right way
forward does anyone opposed to that
okay should we just move on
okay did you I need something else I
just wanted to say that the the um North
County sporting crust could could have
sold this building
but because it's a trampoline and it's
the only area that these kids can use as
a complete trampolining thing that's why
we've ended up in this situation a
minute it is for the benefit of the kids
yeah no no let's get the report uh as
soon as Chris is able to and then we can
make a call but
um
I'll we'll leave you to do your response
to the chair of the trust for Thursday
Chris and the interim it gives an
indication that we're open to that
suggestion though I take that that's the
view here now in opposed to
yeah
okay all right
all right okay so we're at uh page 60
Southbrook
um Chris would be good if you could
follow up uh sorry the um just raise any
questions or Clarity you've had around
the insurance if you could at this point
might just
yeah yeah
foreign
yeah so just on the insurance for
um Southbrook so we've been looking into
um we've been working with Peter Freeman
from the from the club there to have a
look at what it is exactly that they're
currently paying in terms of their
um
in terms of their annual insurance so
they were paying around about fifteen
thousand dollars a year and they also
had another eleven thousand dollars
option on the table if they wanted to
cover seismic concerns so they haven't
actually gone with it they're just
covered under base insurance at this
point in time
um if we were to bring it under
um ourselves uh we're looking at around
about an overall premium of just over
seven thousand dollars
um plus the foreign emergency Levy of
around about just under four thousand
dollars as well
um
we're not sure that that covers all
earthquakes it has stated that it covers
perils such as fire flood and natural
disasters we assume that that would
cover earthquakes but there's a little
bit more that we'll have to do around
that
um so in essence it would be uh
marginally cheaper for us to to cover
that for them
um we're talking around about a saving
of probably about
um four thousand dollars per random on
on their on their insurance it's also
worth noting as well that we've started
with the feasibility study there so
you'll recall that we got some
co-funding from sport Canterbury so
we've actually got a catch-up meeting
tomorrow with Southbrook and the
Consultants to to kind of talk through
that as well so that's currently
underway too so the expectation is that
that will lead us to a bit of a clearer
path for what that club can do in the
future and actually have a look at what
they might be able to do with their
building in terms of
um I guess generating some revenue or
having a look at what the future of that
building might might be
um so yeah there is it would be cheaper
for us to cover their insurance
which means that we should reduce the um
we've supported the 26 000 at the moment
based on the information we have today
we should not support the full 26 but
reduce that by four thousand dollars so
so when the the earthquake amount's not
clear yet though is it
um I've I've had confirmation that
um well they weren't covering that
anyway
um but it would cover if the building
completely fell over they'd get a new
building but if the building didn't fall
over and it was bent then it probably
wouldn't cover
um wouldn't cover that
but with this is all just sort of hot
off the press I'm getting emails from
Syria as I'm sitting here so
um we still need to do some additional
work so the recommendation might want to
be a little bit flexible and say um
support uh approves up to
um a certain amount and leave it with us
to
finalize the details of that insurance
agreement so what is in their budget
sheets here is is the 26k 26 is already
included so up to do you need us to
resolve that or is it you could say up
you could just say up to twenty six
thousand dollars as it's in there now
and we'll we'll make sure we reduce it
it's a review otherwise so why don't we
just just to just change the wording of
up to I don't think we need to amend
that I think that's everyone happy with
that okay
all right so sure sorry question yeah
uh do we know what the Karen tooth quite
code
standard on that building is
no sorry
okay so we'll just keep moving so we're
at uh page we're going to break at one
o'clock we're at page 60.
then 61.
um
62.
just wonder whether this one here this
see if life saving Club there so we're
looking to facilitate to discover
discussions with other clubs in the area
maybe could we add something along the
lines as well as help with a funding
plan with discretionary funders and
utilize the skills of our community team
to help this this group is it is it
possible
Chris is it possible
yeah absolutely great okay if we're
happy to add that wording anyone opposed
to that Council board do you want to say
something I'd very much appreciate when
we respond to them that we give them
some guidance for who they can
communicate with they're totally focused
on raising the fans themselves but they
will need help and assistance from the
community and Recreation or whoever it
can cancel to assist them along the way
in some Gardens okay 63 which is the SC
Rugby Football Club
Yeah question yep well it's not it's a
question it's um it was brought up about
the community board with that there and
they actually
um Logan domain Advisory Board
knew nothing about this so
the football club should be really
working with The Advisory board if
they're wanting to be upgrading it when
the actual Community
um that administered this building
didn't know anything about it
there's been talk for a number of years
to look at a new facility on the lower
area which would be improved facilities
for them The Advisory Group are
absolutely aware of of that a couple of
years ago and people do change but it
was being lead by the Rugby Club more so
than The Advisory Group I don't think it
necessarily changes the recommendations
and here we're going to look at that
funding we've got for replacement and
work with The Advisory Group and those
Affiliated to The Advisory Group which
include the Rugby Club on anything that
we do
okay
so 63 which is a rather well Life Park
foreign
United Football Club
I've done a really good job that club so
if we could just
just
um perhaps just make sure our response
positively reflects without it because
they I was really impressed with the
presentation about the rest of you it
counts the ward yeah I was really
impressed with them too and they're
doing a wonderful job for the Youth of
our district and I just wondered whether
there's um similar to the ATC whether
there's another classroom you know in
rangiora they're up at Marie that their
building is falling down whether
something like a a classroom relocated
just in the interim to give them
something stable to to operate from
until some funds can be raised
yeah yeah um they're actually going to
have uh use of the community sport house
across the road at the stadium plus
we're currently working with the club as
well around the renewal of the
they currently have a building at Maria
Andrews which they've cited is no longer
as fit for purpose but they also don't
need
um the classroom style thing there that
they've actually talked about so with
that building is going
um and instead there's toilets and
storage going back on site so we've been
working very very closely with them Casa
Brian
are they still utilizing the amp grounds
not particularly
um and this is uh I guess that that's
been part of the questioning that we've
had with them as well because we
currently lease that specifically for
them to utilize and also for the high
school
um with the deadly lights now being
operative we're actually seeing quite a
few of the teams going down there and
utilizing that instead
um so it's actually been a really good
investment by Council because we've
diverted use there and
um I guess that question that raises a
question on who might use amp in the
future
40 Grand a year
I think if you could build that into the
answer that the question of council
Awards around the community sport house
across the road it just builds The
Narrative of what we've been doing there
would be helpful
okay uh Cancer Daily yeah just carrying
on with that question with the the
um money that you're paying across to
the showgrounds is that are we spending
money that we don't need to yeah
we're we're talking with the clubs
who've traditionally used it so ideally
it's um or sorry originally it had been
waimakarira United Football Club that
have been using and also the high school
um we're going to be talking with them
over this coming winter around whether
or not they end up utilizing that at all
um if they don't we'd certainly be
reporting back to council to state that
there may no longer need to be at least
paid for here
we also do have lease obligations in
terms of the time frame of that lease as
well so while those exit causes we've
got some sort of obligation there but
we'll come back to council
okay
um so the next one's the kPa
re-advertising page 65.
in 66
okay I think we will call a pause there
let's break for half an hour for lunch
and we'll come back I think we've pretty
much dealt with Westie and small ball
Rifle Club anyway but
we're making good progress okay
I am very happy are we all happy
excellent okay let's break from that I
understand it's down the Green Room
isn't it I think from
yes okay all right we'll be back here at
half past one
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
actually
[Music]
foreign
something fun
well he is a minute
and then we're starting
oh well it's a waste it's always fun
[Laughter]
it's a miracle
yeah that's right it's going to find
this car I've found that incinerated
yeah
yeah I know I'm giving him to 130.
it just went
that's right
is it caused by your car or
yeah it's on the hazard Philip Redmond's
cars on the hazards register officially
all right okay page 66.
see you Courtney thank you
um 67
yes
we are
I think it would be appropriate there
are two options
I think there are four options but
option two
I think the funding should go through
our heritage biodiversity and ecological
fund but we could add to it
and increase funding to the Heritage
fund to cover this grant
rather than make a grant direct to PLC
you so kind of just hold a second
um so you're suggesting that that be the
wording correct okay so that's your
yeah sure before that can we just hold
their questions
uh sorry counselor Stuart actually here
to head up first sorry yeah because I
assume it's a question guess yes it is
clarify
um exactly what is in they Heritage
biodiversity ecological fund because my
understanding at this moment is that we
were proposing to split it into an
ecological fund and a Heritage
structures fund we haven't yet done that
and in fact the total the the fund is
still combined and it has eighty four
thousand dollars
in it
um Can stuff actually comment on that
um yeah so we've taken reports on that
um through I think both land and mortar
and forgive me if I'm incorrect I think
it either went to council or community
and Recreation
um fundamentally those two will be split
as of the first of July this year
um so there will be an ecological and
biodiversity fund and then there will be
a which will be administered by Green
Space there will be a Heritage fund
which will be administered by the
planning department so that it'll still
stay with Matthew Bacon's team
um as far as the Quantum of what they've
put into their fund I couldn't
yep so there's a 42 carried over
um the biodiversity fund
so no so I guess the question of council
Stewarts was how much is actually
sitting in that fund so that's available
to for Heritage buildings well there's
84 in the in the current fund but the
proposal is to split what's currently in
the fund is of the first of July so
there'd be 42 available
um in each of the funds as of the first
of July
yes right at this moment when this
application is being made to the what is
still the combined fund and my
understanding there's an 84 000 sum I
mean arguably if we decided to to Grant
the whole 84 000 to this project the
fund would start with zero in both bits
as of July the first is that correct yes
so I don't know whether so what council
Redmond is proposing is that it goes to
that fund but it's adding an extra
hundred thousand to it is that correct
is that what you were proposing yes or
whatever the figure is that we agree to
put towards it but I think it should go
through that fund
the alternative is councilman Stewart
suggests it could be eighty thousand
dollars if you want to claim that fund
out now
would
um
before we get into it look I don't want
to get into a mess here okay look I'm
going to break this into a workshop
conversation rather than a formal I
think it's tidier
um because it's there'll be a variety of
views on this so counselor Stewart
you see me I'm not actually advocating
um
uh allocating the entire amount though
that was clearly from the submission and
now understanding that um
uh that um
they are a hundred thousand
um in in shortfall from
um what it's going to cost to get that
building up to up to spec for for new
tenants
um
and I just wanted to clarify that in
fact there is eighty four thousand
dollars
um in the combined fund which it is at
the moment and we'll split a July 1st
could you just tell me what is the
ongoing money is it 15 000 a year into
both the split funds as of July the
first is that is that the money that's
allocated
um so the figures as we have them is
that it's
um basically 15
there would be zero for next year
because the intention was to split the
remaining fund that was currently there
so we had any applications this is the
first application yeah so that's one to
the fund that we've had in some time
we're about to get a second by the way
um
um now I'm not sure for the for the
Heritage but so there'd be zero dollars
for next year if there's nothing carried
forward from this year
um in year two there'd be fifteen
thousand dollars in year three there'd
be 25 in year four there would be 35
um and so it increments up like that so
in our current practice is to hold for
three years and to let them build so you
can make meaningful grants but there has
been our present practice it has been up
until now they may well have changed but
that had been our sorry past practice to
well because we didn't lean enough but
that's but that's that's what we've been
doing in the past okay other
other views
so I'm aware that since Stephen's church
in tuahui which is also category one
this is invited out there on Friday with
all the Anglican church and Heritage New
Zealand will also be considering an
application to us at some stage and it's
quite substantial but that that
realistic about what their options are
there in effect the church has indicated
to them that they want to hand it back
to the community but we'll hand it back
they need to hand it back in a good
condition so the support we might be
giving them may well be limited to
planning advice
um just you know
resource consent and other things that
may be required because of its category
but they're looking they're looking at
substantial money to do that building
because it's an it's an interior it's
okay but the exteriors are pretty poor
up here they thought they would just be
able to paint it that's more than just
painting anyway guess about it
so just to clarify the hundred thousand
in the first part of the recommendation
has it been included in our figures Jeff
there's no extra thought it's not
included so anything we put in now yes
that's right
um
my view just is we're in Workshop is
that we should put something in I
definitely want to make a contribution
I'm not convinced on a hundred thousand
um
but if we've got 84 000 sitting there
already I'd like to leave some for the
ecological fund I do agree with
councilor Stewart on that I think that's
really important we've signaled that
that's the way we were kind of gone so
that takes the 42 hour additionally
um there's 42 in there but I wouldn't
have an objection to topping that up to
100 grand for this year it's an effect
adding another sixty thousand yep
58 000. use those numbers correctly
it's well that would be an addition that
would have to go up on the board that's
not something we've currently got and
funded there Council meetings I'm just a
little confused here so you're talking
about a sum of 84 000 yet in number six
on page 68 it says that the fund has
around 42 000 available
so is that so is that specifically
referring to just the Heritage side of
that
it's 2B the funds to be split and it was
designed so that and it was agreed some
time ago I recall but I'm just wondering
this just says that number six has
written
the Heritage biodiversity and ecological
fund so meaning the fund in its entirety
pre-split and it says it currently has
around 42 so it doesn't have 42 or 84.
it's ig4 according to what we were just
saying yeah because I I would not be
Keen to for us to spend the um the
biodiversity ecological money on that
because there's never enough money for
those projects as it is yeah so I think
we would need additional funding
um if we were going to put anything into
it we just I think we need some clarity
from staff but we've been advised that
sitting at 84 000 presently is that
right
well I think I think we need some clear
Clarity on this before we decide so I'm
happy to hold this measure and come back
to it
um can we do that please and we'll come
back to that conversation I think we
need to be clear what we have actually
got there
yes and also
um it would be helpful to know that
there's no
no commitments sitting presently against
that 84k
um
but we just for purposes of clarity
before we start spinning against it
let's be clear but there are others in
the community who have signaled that
they'll be putting applications in more
than so you've also got the likes of the
rangiora lawn bowls
yeah so we need
might be might be tidier to top the fund
up and to consider it through its usual
process but to look at a an ongoing we
should be an ongoing amount at the top
there to that fund up would be so look
could stuff give that some thought and
we'll come back to that conversation in
a minute once we know what where their
fund's presently sitting so I'm just
going to put that on hold for the moment
we'll come back to that okay so the next
has been dealt with I believe oh this is
the Oxford Arts trust or Not by McCree
Arts trust
um just in the the
um in the recommendation to the
submitter I think we should be noting
only that we already provide a grant of
around five almost six thousand to help
their organization with the insurance
and other fixed costs it's still
occurring I I confirmed it with gfus
today is it you just just check what
that amount is but we should put that in
there
okay
everyone happy with this
so I hook a domain so that's in there
it's recommending in the sheets to the
ten thousand dollar donate uh continues
that's an ongoing amount Chris is not
I think we've just identified it for the
next three years
okay
which is what we've done previously and
that's why it fell off
but it was previous a long time ago it
was ongoing and then we did it at the
last long-term plan just for three years
and that's why we've had to redo that
now all right okay
um any any views okay Life Education
Trust
see if lifeguard Patrol so we so just so
I'm clear from this from what I see from
the white sheets we're actually
increasing
the um
amount by twenty thousand dollars is
that right
yeah that's right and and this is due to
um
Market increases in
um wages for lifeguards or can we make
that clear on what we put back to the
submitica that's not clear in the
writing here of that so if we could just
clarify what the grant will increase to
and that's ongoing
well there'd also be inflation-proofed
use it as inflation proof through the
budget
um
yes okay call anyone
everybody happy with that
he gives us resonance
so 72
73.
76.
h
75 hmm
just a question of stuff my
understanding is that the
this area actually lost its peddling
pool and earthquakes in it was promised
that it would be replaced at some point
with some sort of
facility
is
so we are looking at really working
seriously with them on this
particular project
um I'll try the to answer that but Matt
at the back of the room is
waiting desperately for the moment
here's your moment
[Laughter]
um but you Met's been working with fine
security beaches Association for the
last month to have a look at what's
possible on the site talking with our
Engineers around what's also possible
um I I can't recall
um at any time that we've actually
promised the planes correctly
features Association that we would put
something back they have actually this
is a submission that we've received
every long-term plan since I've been at
Council so since the earthquakes and
each time
um the council hasn't decided to put any
funding towards it
um we've been quite clear that
um with the group that we're happy to
put staff time into investigating what's
possible down there
um however it's not likely they're going
to get
um
get back what it is that they had
originally and that's just simply based
on the amount of people that are there
and that this would serve us and the
expense of a peddling pool which which
is huge
um so but there are lots of different
options that we can can look at um it'll
be lovely if we could just put a a
sprinkler on the lawn but
um we can't do that anymore and it gets
really really complicated because the
water has to go somewhere and be treated
and and all the rest of that sort of
stuff so
um we'll continue to work with them and
and come back with uh probably to the
board with with what we come up with but
inevitably
it's it's not likely to be cheap
um no matter what we do down there
um and and I guess we have to justify
the expense based on the number of
people that still live in that community
and the benefit they'll get and the
other facilities that we have the
Aquatic strategy that we recently did
didn't identify this as a need in the
community
um but it is something that they did
have and they don't have any longer so
do you have anything to admit
they identified they might be able to
get some local individuals who had
funding nothing actually came of that
but whether or not that was just because
they had we were still working towards
getting a full picture of what what it
was going to cost we had a rough idea of
just the the feature itself but then as
Chris identified you've got the war test
to go somewhere there's weather the
infrastructure in the ground can support
the incoming and outgoing water parking
seating fencing all of those aspects
which we just didn't have the time to
prepare in time for this
um when we do look at this can we make
sure that we look at it from a district
point of view that Community a community
of that size having this level of
service within their
um within that oval was in my view cost
wise not effective but if it's actually
looked at from the point of view that it
would be a splash pad within the
district then there may be some hope for
it the argument that councilman actually
puts forward actually isn't a correct
one they were not promised to they were
down for a replacement paddling pool at
the time when the earthquake fit hit
that was argued that that should be a
splash pad the community did not want a
splash pad they only wanted the pedaling
pool
replaced and at that point
for the community board which it was
then Dr community board had rejected
that and and recommended to council that
that go away on a population basis after
the earthquake so it was all tied up in
that we had this many people then the
earthquake came and there wasn't that
many people and it was difference
between a paddling pool and a splash pad
and it and so it was actually taken away
at that point and the community argued
it was taken away the community board
and the council argued that that was not
the case that that was actually
something that happened as a as uh
population size so if we look at it as a
a
um across the district might may or may
not out there Castle Becky
residents there
um
their proposal was for a splash pad
because that correct me if I'm wrong
that's a whole lot cheaper than a pool
and and comment you just made Matt about
fencing why did why does a splash pad
which is only a lump of concrete on the
ground why does it have to be fenced
anyway it doesn't we're just trying to
make sure we look at all the aspects of
of if if we trigger different aspects of
like so do we need to put barbecues or
seating and all those sorts of other so
fencing off the road all of that those
things maybe as a suggestion as a Way
Forward is that we call for a report on
this
um and which brings brings back to us
what the options are because uh we're
not in a position to resolve this today
and necessarily we don't have a costume
we don't have any of that so let's get a
report come back to us and if we could
weave that into the response to the
submitter the council's report uh
request the report on the options of
what's been requested around this um a
splash pad right is it a way forward it
is a way forward but again can we do the
timing thing this is another five or six
report so if we're going back to the
respond and it'd be nice to get some
form of how long that's going to take
yeah
well why can't this go to next year's
annual plan
but I think in this instance we need a
report in which to consider that before
the annual plan so a report that would
give us that ability to make that
decision
just mindful of stuff as well and that
we can deal with this at next year's
annual plan by that time we will have a
report with all the appropriate yeah so
maybe if we just word it that way we're
all happy with that okay
um
uh 17 sorry Lu did you have a question
uh 79
ac2
there's just some weeding around here
um I think I think the second
unfortunate says unfortunately the
council has significant that last
sentence and that first paragraph I
think should come out
um
yes it is so the cut this is the
response to some of the customer
undertake this week would be a direct
call on the general rate pay at the time
and the council was committed to ensure
it plays its part in affordable living
well
um I I think it would be something along
the lines of also there's consideration
of other museums in the district
um in the in the requirements but that
just that sentence doesn't resonate
um well with me I had the rest you feel
with that
because it's always a judgment call we
have every year
um yeah
direct email question asking if all of
these were going to be passed through
comms to actually make the wording they
are going to be appropriate so are we
supposed to be commenting on it what I'm
saying to you
to be honest if there are some things
that you have a strong objection to let
it know be known but otherwise if it's
minor weeding then that the the default
position as you said we'll be going
through comms with that view but I just
when I saw that one that's one that
really did stick out to me right
um
okay so 18 oh sorry yes
yeah no that's it's coming it's coming
out yes yep
um 83
yep
I just wonder if I could ask the staff
uh response doesn't really address both
issues
they ask this is the museum or kaiapoi
District Historical Society for an
additional elevator to use we're in the
answer to that is no or making the
elevator already in the building
accessible to the museum that last card
isn't referred to anywhere and I just
wonder if that is an option that could
be looked at
the the current
lift that's in there doesn't access the
area that they're wanting to get into so
there's whilst it's available there for
them to use it's not actually getting to
the it's not getting to the area that
they want it to so they've got all their
storage at the back
um above where their office space is
it's just got no correlation with the
area no could there not be a brunch
across
from that level to their storage area
um
know their significant structural
changes to the building it would be a
huge cost to do that
um
so we've tried to come up with a
solution which is provided if they have
large things they want to move then we
can give them assistance to be able to
move those large things bearing in mind
the fact that the actual display doesn't
change on a regular basis so they can
work with us on the timing of that we've
also got staff available in there which
would be
um
fitter and stronger than some of the
members of the um
some of the members of the
character of the year the museum so
yeah
back in the day Craig saginson looked at
putting a bridge across I don't think he
got as far as costing it but it's across
the city
it's not it's not you can't just put two
planks across
yep okay well could that be covered in
the response because they did ask the
two people I think I think can we just
broaden that response that here's the
answer good point
okay
um still on that page the top
Mrs Mr Alistair leech I think it's leech
L double a c h just so okay
it doesn't change the answer
um
um 84
.
85 I just wonder if on these art storage
and storage space something created in
there that we will arrange for staff to
discuss this
um with the museum and report back to
council because it has been asked for a
couple of times we did request it at a
previous
um it was the annual plan around this
and I'm not sure what the what the
response back to those that I think
Craig was looking into that wasn't he
yeah we've actually got all the
information sitting there we've been to
Iron Mountain and we've got the prices
for mine Mountain on storage and um can
you report that back to us at some point
we could come back with options of that
East Belt Building being used but now
there's other options that have come
available in other buildings and the
current a current report would be
helpful yep
okay
okay 85 so just was looking at that
answer I I'd scribbled something here
but I can't understand my scribble so if
I can't understand it you're not going
to be able to 86
um
yeah we've
oh no we did look at that some years ago
uh Chris didn't want to respond to that
yeah it's um
I've talked to Craig sargison and Paula
esket about this and they both have
completely contradicting views
um about Outreach Services for libraries
um Craig in his career went through a
long process of removing Outreach
libraries and consolidating libraries
into into one space
um so that it was more of a Community
Connection space and Paula's you know
times change and we tend to go in
circles and
um Paul has talked a lot about Outreach
Services to be able to connect with
communities that can't connect with the
library and also to to promote what they
do
um the simple fact is we don't have a
bus we don't have anything that we can
actually take books but it's not
necessarily the books that people want
in in library Outreach Services at some
of the other services that actually
provide like digital literacy
Etc and all of those things
um you don't actually need a bus or
anything it's actually just a librarian
going to a community facility and being
able to provide those services in a
community facility so
um they are looking at options of how
they can extend that into other parts of
the district at the moment
okay uh 80 so 86 87 just at the bottom
of the submission from Madeleine I just
I had a feeling my recollection was
Midland talked quite a lot on social
housing and I'm wondering if we could
please add into that answer that we
formed a social housing working party
and just paired it out a bit and because
she did talk about that when she came to
see us she was talking about every field
and other things for memory
as I just I didn't pick it up earlier
but anyway um if it is let's cover there
but anyway
um all right
um disc golf so 87
91.
picks up our decision from this morning
I think it needs to edit near the next
steps that we're taking which is a
resource consent all those sort of
things
dismissing that and then answer
we could just stand there then
it's 33 so 94.
96.
103.
it's that silver stream now 104
yep
soaked up the response to um
about the Croco Club
the card will have to welcome the
emerald but could we also include in
there the synergies between what we did
with the land at
the other land at Murphy Park when
Riverside bowling Club went across
because it's the same situation yeah if
we could refer to the you know I don't
know president's been said whichever way
that may be just sort of throw a bit of
that in the in the answer
thank you
I don't think I think the point and
pointing here is that the club are very
happy with it
um with what we're doing Michael was
alleging something that just doesn't
where the club is sitting so
so I'm sure they'll
yeah
103 104
the piece of control in the oh
which is what I've got to added some
money in here too haven't we
did it in seven thousand
um
wondering are we sitting a precedent for
other ecological areas especially I
think it's totally deserved uh we're
sitting a precedent for other ecological
areas in the district first question and
secondly how
effective will a pest control
um
program B in an area that's getting
close to closer to residential areas
are you really good questions
um we actually had a presentation at the
last community and Recreation committee
meeting from one of the Rangers Who's
down there at the moment
um NCS she identified the fact that the
bird counts which have been going on
down there have seen a 33 increase in
bird numbers since the pest control has
been operation operating down there it's
all been done by volunteers at the
moment I would say that the amount of
plants that we've planted in the
ecosystem we've established down there
um
is all for nothing if we don't then
actually do the pest control to allow
the species to move in and actually have
that as as viable habitat there are
other areas in the district where it is
successful would be the trust land at
tikahakara to hotel trustly and they do
a huge amount of volunteer and
ranger-led Pest Control
to make sure that this control is
um uh something which is measured in
something which we are spending the
right money in the right places you do
need to do an ecological study we need
to we've done boot counts but we need to
understand exactly what we've got and a
point in time so that we can go back and
then actually test that at a later date
to see if we're making real impact in
the reserve so that's why there's a
recommendation also to to have that
ecological study done
um they have found some some pretty
awesome stuff there over the last year
since the Rangers have been there
there's a a small ground plant species
which is the only one of its type found
in the last 15 years on the side of the
Divide so that sort of thing needs to be
protected but we also need to actually
know whether these things are there in
terms of Precedence
um
we we have lots of other areas which we
have native Bush and we're also looking
at projects like arohatia TR we're going
to be creative creating native Bush as
well so
um I don't see it as a negative thing to
create a precedence to say that when we
are investing in the creation of native
Forest areas that we're also spending
the money to make sure that those areas
can be utilized by the right
biodiversity and protected so
um there may be in the future for the
bids for further Pest Control
and um we don't do any Active Pest
Control at the moment it's all through
volunteers and we're just providing them
some assistance
so can I just ask how they were funded
previously if they've been already been
doing it uh they've got grants from
um various
um external organizations and and other
places to be able to get that up and
running and buy their traps and all the
Labor's just been done by themselves
the Oxford Hoka community board
they also provided funding for the
Ashley Gorge Reserve Advisory Group to
buy traps for that area as well
hmm
um cancer Duty
thing that was really going to your
local
organization the men's shed to to build
traps is a really good option
okay
um
Council Atkinson yeah I just wanted to
given the questioning and answers
whether whether it's time to have a look
at look at a collective program whether
it's run by us or another trust or if
we've got three that we've just set
around the table and talked about that
are all doing three different things
what are the synergies that should be
and how should these work groups be
working together to make sure then could
be across the district in the future but
I think we need to even if we can
instigate someone maybe it's Greg Franti
kohaka to um
inch to get a a good look at what's
happening across the district because
I'm sure there's other groups out there
doing it as well
um so at the moment we're looking at the
creation of an environmental strategy
and there will be some actions which
come out of that environmental strategy
and they'll look at the um the inputs
and outputs that we've got at the moment
um pretty to free
um 2050 those sorts of central
government programs and whether or not
we should be more actively involved in
that space and what other external
support we can get at the moment
um I would say the the level of council
um funding towards Pest Control other
than a bit of rabbit and here control is
has not been huge but that's that's just
because of priorities and and resource
and we're starting to move into that
with volunteers so it'll get picked up
and then there could be some actions but
there'll be lots of discussion around it
just on that
um the waimakaruri biodiversity trust is
um has had a call for trustees and it
will be a district-wide trust this is a
an action out of the water Zone
committee uh you have agreed to give
some seed funding towards some
um the operations of of that group when
it gets going that trust and one of
their
um priorities will be pest control and
you may like to
um tag funding particularly or or
um or support uh peace control right so
certainly your question is
okay all right sorry thank you um
yes I'd like to move an amendment
too
I've got no problem with the one or four
thousand ground
there's the 3 000 per annum I'd like to
move that it's 3 000 for this financial
year
with and a b tube say that notes that a
review will be done of the pistol review
pest control and ecological projects in
the district with a view to Future fund
so can we just go through the three
thousand dollars
for this year this financial you're not
fair enough 21 22 Yeah in review of pest
control and ecological assessment
program for the whole District to be
carried out
there's some appear to Second yeah
secreted by accounts that concerned just
tell us about it just noting this um I'm
absolutely 100 in control of control and
it's important of what um is being done
at silverstream I think it's an
absolutely fantastic initiative I've
been down there I've walked the tracks
um I'm I can't applaud the volunteers
enough but we've got a volunteers at our
hokabosh we've got volunteers at Ashley
Gorge we've got volunteers who want to
bring the Tui down from the mountains
we've got tikohaka we've got some
wonderful wonderful programs and I just
would like to have a more holistic view
of where our money's going and where we
can get the most benefit with with
Predator control you've got to be so
careful when you're near to residential
areas because basically you're wasting
your time if you spend a lot of time
doing it and then people are living
there with who've already got predators
in their households so I'm a bit
concerned that we're doing these
one-offs and I'd like to see a more
holistic program to benefit the whole
District so that we can make sure that
we're spending that money wisely
we've got several people doing several
different things and Chris just
explained where
um that review could actually come from
if you like because it's going to be
tied up and what's what's already
happening and um I'm not I'm not going
to die on the ditch over three grand uh
a year if you get what I mean but the
review is important but for me because I
do agree I mean we've got a whole heap
of pest control going on this District
we don't know what it is and you we are
willing to fund on an ongoing basis
something that we don't know
um is one doing any good is it done the
right way and I'm not suggesting that
it's not by any stretch of the
imagination you know and and several
other of these things going on in there
in our district in all sorts of areas so
I think that it is time for us to have a
look and see what it is and who knows
what comes out of that you know I mean
we've got the uh the zero Pierce control
which is an aspiration of the government
um you know where we where we can tap
into and what what is it that they're
doing and are we aligned and according
to them they've got the best system that
there is so
um are we tapping into those systems and
all of those sorts of things we don't
know we've just got a whole heap of
separate individual things going on
around our district which are probably
doing a great job but we don't know
okay any further speakers
counts Redmond
um I'm not opposed to the motion but I
just wondered if we are looking at
Predator control how effective is that
if we don't have a predator control
boundary I mean we're fighting a
never-ending uh battle I would suspect
okay any further speakers rather reply
oh do you wish to speak he's just
wondering because because we
okay yep but no fear the speakers no
other reply I'll put the re
I'll put the well it's Amendment
um all those a favor please say I can't
treat
clear that carried
okay
so we're at
108.
and 109 I thought was the best of all
actually
um all their pages that we've had today
excellent work team
[Laughter]
foreign
all right so 110
um these is this this is still you for a
while across no you done
now um hold on we've got a we do have
you need to come back to us about the
heritage
yes so um are you prepared to answer
that question now or do you need a bit
more time
because I can bring you back
Grant have you got a suggested Way
Forward as well
um before we finish today we'll come
back to that
um so we'll could I
well we can't now because you need staff
if I've asked for more time so can I
um suggest that we've come back to this
topic around 4 30. please thank you
yeah of course
you can take in and out it's like
getting into a bus in Auckland you don't
take off you get charged right
all right so we're now at
um we're gonna hold one it says it's uh
let me just
yeah
hold on yeah
Simon is that Simon
um I'm just checking in because Jared's
following his name yep so in your whites
with the whites we've got Christmas
events
and they will deal with the white the
main pages
well we've got a we've got a Christmas
events funding one to deal with is there
anything else that Simon's got in here I
think the rest are all UNR
let's deal with it and then we'll get
into the
pages so we're in if we can go back into
the main agenda
so in the summary agenda it's page six
Pages 202 to 213 Christmas events
funding
thanks Simon
uh good afternoon so
this report follows up a request for
information to be brought to the this
meeting which
um for the three promotions associations
gave you a sense of
how they're going with the current uh
Christmas events funding uh contribution
from a council how those events are
going and there's a range of responses
back from the three promotions
associations
which give you a financial breakdown of
how they most recent uh Christmas parade
event went and some commentary which is
slightly different from each of the
um each of the promotions associations
the short of it is at the moment uh
kaiapoi and rangiora are on their most
recent financial performance made a
small Surplus on their Christmas event
now they are in
compared to other contexts such as
Oxford they're they're a little more
fortunate in that they're more likely to
attract sponsorship funding at their
larger events
and there's a larger pool of resource to
draw on
um Oxford uh uh promotions action
committee
passed the majority of the event Grant
to the Lions to implement the event and
have uh reported a concern about the
share the proportion of that grant that
is consumed in traffic management and it
is a higher proportion than for the
other events
um I note in the report that not all of
the funding that is provided to OPEC to
implement a Christmas parade is actually
passed over
to the lions that is not a criticism
it's simply a commentary and that
retained funds are used to promote a
related event at that time of year
I think the recommendation principally
is to
work with OPEC and the Lions to see how
we can ensure that that event continues
to happen in an appropriate way
with the funding that is provided by
Council and any other sources of funding
that they are able to bring to bear on
it happy to answer any questions
cute Christians Council Duty thank you
um just a question on this is
um
would it be possible just to provide the
money the fund extra funding
for the um the traffic management
because
I'm not trying to be cute anything's
possible
um but but it requires a consideration
of the funding for all of the these
events so all of them are funded to a
certain degree that the amount of
funding that is provided doesn't cover
the full cost of the event they need to
fundraise and and in order to do that if
you wish to
Advance additional funds that's that's
that's entirely possible I guess the
question that I have to ask is if not
all of the money that is made available
by the council has passed over to the
entity that is charged with running the
event
um that that's a question that I think
needs to be addressed between OPEC and
OPEC and and the Lions so uh there are
you know a a fifth of the funding is
retained by OPEC for other purposes it
now they use that to to support another
very worthy event and I'm acutely aware
of that counselor but the council gave
the funding for the purpose of a
Christmas parade and at this stage on
the facts before us not all of that
money is being passed over to the entity
that is charged to deliver that parade
and I think that's the point of
conversation okay with the with the
association or the committee that is
appropriate
okay did you ever hear the question well
yes yes I do actually so the question is
do you not think the Christmas carols
are sort of all Incorporated with the
whole of the Christmas theme
I I certainly think that's a celebratory
event at the same time of year but I
have to go back to what was the purpose
for which the funding was allocated and
and it was allocated to OPEC to deliver
a parade
and and I'm not trying to be at all
critical of OPEC or uh undermine the
worthiness of the other event but it is
is not what was intended
any further questions
uh Council Redmond
uh thank you Mr Mia I think I read a
fairly detailed response from a board
member from Oxford to Hoka
your agenda yes okay um
is there a problem if the funds are
simply Advanced to OPEC to organize a
Christmas parade and Christmas carols
does that not solve the problem
I'm not sure it would solve the problem
of the Quantum of the costs associated
with delivering the parade enter to to
to ask OPEC to then deliver both of
those events with that amount of money
when when the agent that they're using
to deliver one of those events is saying
it is it is not enough with respect I'm
not sure that answers the problem that
is before the council and OPEC any
further questions we've got to say
counselor about it
Simon looking at the traffic management
costs for each of the three areas it
does appear that the the grant for
Oxford is quite low for traffic
Management in terms of the type of area
it's um it's only using a very small
area but it is a main road
um how was it decided to fund each these
different amounts
that's a very good question that I think
predates me and my association with the
waimakuru district council I guess I'd
observe out of a a grant of of the order
of uh seven thousand dollars about forty
percent three thousand is going to
traffic management at Oxford out of a
grant of eleven thousand dollars or or
they're about twelve thousand to kaiapoi
rangiora 9000 is going to traffic
Management in rangiora so uh
proportionately there is a more
um there is a a parade that is uh
experiencing a higher burden of cost if
you like for traffic management the
difference I guess is that rangiora has
the opportunity to fundraise and so you
see the budget for the event that is
funded substantially beyond the council
is very much larger and and that's the
that is the Dilemma before us and so the
recommended course of action I think is
to
try and work this through on the current
funding allocation
with OPEC and the lions and if that
proves to be
uh not sustainable then I think we'll
we'll need to think again but uh in the
that was the course of action that is
set out in the report for your
consideration okay so six there's
recommendations I'm prepared to move
some would be the second
counselor Atkinson
um
I think I think this is the appropriate
Way Forward I I
am um I'm aware that Oxford Lions have
certainly mentioned to me that from
their perspective unless the grant
amount has increased for to cover the
traffic management then they won't
uh run the parade so I think this is a
conversation directly with
um opaque and Oxford lions with our
staff to see if a resolution can be
achieved if it's going to require it
some additional funding then that's a
matter that may need to come back to us
for consideration I I've got an open
mind to that I want to see Christmas
personally love going to our parades in
our district I really would be a real
shame if we lost the Christmas parade in
Oxford for the sake of a few thousand
dollars or whatever the sum is let's see
if we can broker an arrangement there
that works for both the Christmas and
the park is also really popular I know
straight after the Christmas parade in
rangiora they run Christmas in the Park
a lot of that is directly funded by
sponsorship Oxford's not in the same
situation easily to raise it so the
level of sponsorship with the level of
businesses that are there and I know
there's a lot of Goodwill that goes into
running these the lines don't make
anything out of this this is something
they do do purely for community
and and look so do all our
um promotions associations that are in
these because they're doing it for the
right reasons which is to promote the
towns and provide Christmas so as easy
as we can make it would be appreciated
so I think D is the penultimate section
and Simon if you need you and the team
need to come back with a an arrangement
posted let us know because I I just
would hate for Christmas to be gone from
the town of Oxford the sake of a mic
well what is in our budget a minor
amount of money but it's still on the
rate pair ultimately so the right course
of action is to try and see if we can
negotiate an outcome that's positive
this might come in briefly it's not my
intention to be the Christmas Grinch I
knew I know
yeah well I Know You Still Believe In
Father Christmas Simon apparently all
right um second to council ringtone um
does there any further speakers
I'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye contrary to clear
that carriage
right so if we we have one meter while
you're here Simon before we come to the
pages that some public excluded
um we might deal with that now which is
the
um kaiapoi South did you want to deal
with that while you're here
foreign
okay why don't we deal with it now so
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
before
really
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
pages
uh page 118 yup either uh well one one
one one I was the one that we were
coming to first I think oh apologies
it's you're right sorry in the in the
book we'll get to one Monday pretty soon
it's the diligent number versus the book
number so I'm just um yeah you'll need
to just remind me where you stopped on
this process
um so will um because I will stop when
you and I starts Mr Beer okay all right
that's fine I will just double double
checking so all right so we're at one so
we're at page so we're now back in open
meeting
110 okay
111 just you stay just here
thanks Simon
Community outcomes transport is it still
you Simon you and VJ
sorry
so where do we
where do we next and to see have you got
any other pages in here that we need to
deal with yeah so I'll come back to 115.
well to be honest wouldn't we just deal
with it while we're here because to be
perfectly honest it shouldn't be
terribly difficult
one one five
one one six there's any yep that someone
wants to ask something or yep we're
happy good just checking
um
118.
122.
123.
125 you're keeping up that's good
so 126 this is around the car parking
building
into a note that that's coming to
Council next week's Simon isn't that yep
there's a report coming to Council next
week around that matter yep 127
129.
130.
[Music]
oh
you pay the bill
I mean the
yeah oh they're chew here
just to 133 in the staff recommendation
um might just put can we just seek into
the last paragraph when we refer to
option A can we just explain and remind
people what option A is in case they
don't know it's just a point I picked up
before Oh so I'm going to read those
papers 134
well this is really into Joey and
narrows not really
is there any other pages that you're
required for Simon
you're a heavy camper
well hold on let's just deal with 150 I
don't know deal with 136
okay I'm gonna pause there there's
nothing else for you on these Pages
Simon that you wanted to deal with when
you use
think if this covid-19 as well
okay well let's just carry on and if we
need Joanne we
um
140.
sure yep
use your microphone please thank you
page 141 officer recommendation six
fifty thousand dollars and the 23-24
year
I would like to suggest it come forward
by one year
there are a whole lot of issues around
pigs hold on hold on say it's a question
first is that question to staff yes
staff could this be brought forward to
by one year
um yes it could come forward
um the the funding that would be
provided for that is normally allocated
to advice such as
um transport experts Urban Design
experts and the like there is also a
secondary uh thought process around
staff resourcing to project manage that
we've got a an LED strategy or sorry A
Local Economic Development strategy
which is which is coming up this year
which will be out the way
um and a couple of other bits and pieces
but there's no reason why it couldn't be
brought forward we might just have to
reorganize some projects in the back end
as well so it's absolutely able to come
forward yeah
um Council Blackie
it's going up still on item six that the
words
um Ravens would be included in that
strategy it's it's not really a wooden
Pig strategy it's a that's the whole
it's the trio it mentions that on the
bottom of 140 but it doesn't mention it
yeah under six can you put Raven to it
just to make it clear yeah oh we're not
we're not we're not well hold a second
can I I said a question before we start
Council Redmond asked around the years
um I just would like to look we've got a
discussion coming up a little colleague
shortly around managing workload and
expectations
um I'd just like to be clear that um do
we have the capacity to deliver on this
project sooner than what you've
indicated
um we're just working through the
implications of the Town Center Program
which has been included into this ltp so
in the background or you've been
considering the numbers we've been
considering the implication of
implementing as as is planned in the
draft ltp
um it's certainly possible Mr Mayor it
just might mean a reshuffling of
projects and I couldn't tell you at the
stage what projects left that would
actually mean would have there's there's
a round 20 projects over the next year
between Vanessa and I that we need to to
be working on so we just need to which
projects would be reshuffled to do this
so
we couldn't say that right here and now
um I'm from our point of view your your
desire is I think for you is to bring It
Forward well I suggest that if you
proceed with that we will if we're going
to have issues with delivering that or
having to make tough calls between that
and other projects that's not till the
22-23 year so we've got
all of 21 22
to monitor progress on the projects for
that year to come back to you with
advice about the program and priorities
for 2223 but we're not uncomfortable for
you to bring that that money forward I'm
we are aware that the wood end
um
Ashley community board is is anxious to
get this piece of work done sooner
rather than later and we obviously would
like to be responsive to that so so we'd
need an amendment to bring that forward
so you're proposing
cancer treatment that come forward 22-23
is it right
is there someone here to second that so
second of counts the ballot
Council Reedman do you wish to speak
uh no just to say there was some feeling
that it would be useful to have this
work completed sooner rather than later
but I am conscious of staff workloads
that time if it's possible then I think
that's great who cares about it
um yes I was involved in the previous
wooden Pegasus strategy that's all they
were saying that's what it was called
back then
um and it's well over Joe the action
points are completely out of date the
area is growing at such a rapid amount
it was probably growing more than we
thought it would Ravenswood has taken
off as a subdivision and so that
northward India are connecting it into
wood end and connecting Pegasus into
that there's some serious issues need to
be addressed and so I totally respect
that we've got District plan work that
we've got parking work but this is the
third largest urban area in our district
and it has as I said it missed out
because of the earthquake everything got
pushed out it needs some urgent
attention and I would like to see it as
a priority project
yeah just to look very quickly I won't
be sporting this because I don't know
what else is going to suffer because we
do this in until such time as I I've not
scared to bring it bring it forward if I
knew what what else was happening in the
background but I don't
and until I know that then I'll be
voting against the amendment
I'm going to support the amendment
because I I did our staff very clearly
if there was reservations around that I
appreciate that they haven't got all the
projects here but they seem to be
relaxed with us coming forward if that
was the desire certainly it has been a
desire in that community that this work
has brought forward has been also a view
that they'd like to establish a
Coastal promotions organization to sort
of kind of fits with all that is going
on in the growth in the area so I'm
relaxed about bringing it Forward based
on the answers of our staff any further
speakers
I'll put the recommend sorry write a
reply
I'll put the recommendation just
changing the dates there all those in
favor please say all right
country no to clear that carried
no declared so who would likely votes
recorded no
to just just Council Atkinson
okay
um
143 oh yep sorry yes I'm a page 142 that
term they're currently unanticipated in
the plan with um I can't quite
understand that we we allocated two
million the covert recovery and we've
spent 700 thou and another 300 hours
allocated so there's still a mill
um in in the pot why why is that called
unanticipated
elevated
I I think
um from memory I might be corrected by
um Mr Millwood but I think we had uh
right at the beginning of the covert uh
done an assessment of about two million
uh that we thought that the covert event
might cost the council
um uh at the LA at the last count where
I took those numbers from
um I think we were significantly under
there and we'd made provision for 300
000 but we hadn't anticipated drawing
down any more than that uh the I guess
what I'm saying in this report is
we would need to draw down further from
that loan uh if if you wanted to support
uh the the recommendations of the
association
and I guess they they haven't
necessarily specified uh numbers and or
programs to what to what that money
would actually be allocated to and we
haven't had any advice from ENC that
would support that at this point in time
so I guess my recommendation was carry
on and monitor and discuss rather than
signal and allocation of the funding and
draw down further on the loan
PNC or anyone else came back with some
with some figures that some more funds
would be available
uh absolutely we could bring a report to
council and have Council consider
whether they will wish to to further
fund those activities that were being
signaled as needed but it would be
another decision of council I think to
to exercise some more of that loan
uh 140 thank you 143
we did have a submission around this
from
um the Oxford hiker community board in
fact uh strongly mentioned by
um board member Farrell around the
concerns around the location of the
Oxford site in fact encouraged us while
in Oxford to have a look at that site if
we get any response to that point
because there was there was a strong
view of the board that was expressed was
that it's the wrong location and that it
should be in another location I'd just
like to know what staff's response to
that is and if
uh very early on in the project we
looked at a number of sites and
uh had conversations with the Oxford
promotions Association around those
sites along with others we also brought
a report to council very early on on the
project and I would understand if
members don't remember that but at
explored options uh location options in
all of the different towns from that
point we then worked with Meridian who
are the substantive funder of these
things and have a significant commercial
interests and the location of these
sites particularly around the cost of
installation and what they believe to be
good locations for the network
and so many of those decisions are sort
of greatly influenced by the fact that
they are the substantive Thunder of
these these sites and so I believe if we
had have pushed for other sites we would
have been asked to either further fund
those locations at reasonable cost or
that Meridian would have opted to back
out of those those sites so I just can't
remember which side the board preferred
over
yeah
um I just I guess it's just making sure
we have got the the concern they raised
was that they they believed here that
they weren't consulted or communication
on the on the preferred location
uh so so the uh promotions Association
were as the key instigator of this
project brought along with all of those
um the reports brought to council with
site location options were also
circulated to the community boards and
further discussion was had with the
community board at one point on those
albeit again I I there's been a lot of
information in front of them so I
understand if they don't remember that
all right Cass Friedman
uh Simon I think there may be a typo at
the bottom of page 146.
the second to last line I think the word
no may be missing in front of financial
is that correct
yes
um cancer Duty
thank you just a query on this and this
is a reason why
the the boxes I don't know what they're
called those big boxes for electricity
Char whatever they are not Transformers
Transformers that's that there's a
larger Transformer at the Oxford Town
Hall in a smaller green box where they
wanted to go and as and what I'm asking
is is that the reason why because
there's more
a bigger
service there
not not per se counselor it's prominence
visibility patronage that Meridian are
favoring the site that was their
preference what we you know and and
that's the commercial component to it
because we're not funding this other
than providing a site I think the other
factor that we'd have to bear in mind uh
would be the costs of getting
electricity at the right uh you know
what what connectivity is there to any
to Alternative sites now so the first
seven the site assessment was
visibility and hence patronage
and then you rule out a certain range of
sites or at least you have a sense of
priority or preference and then you
drill down to those smaller number of
sites in terms of what then is the cost
to get electricity
unfortunately this project and while
we're in uh public but
the
uh understanding of Meridian at the
beginning in terms of the costs and
Logistics of power supply as compared to
when they finally got quotes for this is
materially different so they are much
more conservative in terms of looking at
Alternatives
and and that's why we're down to one
charger at initially anyway at Oxford
rather than more at this point in time
so the location's been well considered
okay I it answers the question because
we we think it has Mr mere Council that
that all reasonably practical options
have been considered and way and weighed
up over now quite a quite an extensive
period of time
Casa Duty okay and my my question was is
the other side that they that we feel is
better but that wasn't really
um it wasn't all sealed and and things
like the time when Meridian looked at it
previously and then it's actually a
really Clear Sight but it's been done
and dusted now so well just well it's
not unmute so as just ask the question
it's not it's not installed you does it
so that location has that because it has
now been sealed I think it's near the
tree there is is it possible to just see
whether that's a possibility before it's
confirmed and we can always ask I think
the the issue will be we we have now a
license and a lease in place with Oxford
so we would be essentially asking them
to change the terms of them can we just
can we just put the question and then
just see where we get to and that'll
probably answer that matter but at least
we've shown
um that I have some sympathy for what is
being at because it is a more central
location than where the town hall is but
if we've been there I also negotiated a
contribution from main power with
Vanessa to get it at that location so I
wouldn't want to undo all this either so
but if you could and it's possible that
would be appreciated
and just just a question about it so are
you talking about isn't that where the
farmer's market is on a Saturday morning
and other functions are held to get into
Pearson Park would it not remove the
ability the ability to charge in the
weekend when you've got uh certainly
Saturday mornings at wood because that's
where the family of markets set up so
the car park we've taken back on the
road normally out there but anyway so if
they could be looked at and I think I
think what Neville was Raising there
would be if it does it's probably a
conversation with the farmers market
organizer to make sure that wouldn't be
it and this shoe but I don't want to
create a whole workload issue that comes
from that thank you
all right 146 uh 147
through climate change and
sustainability you're still with us you
two
yeah okay good good stuff uh 148.
149.
150.
these are differently underwriting now I
think there's nothing else in here that
relates to yourselves
you've got finance and business support
papers
uh well that's Jared Syria
action on Heritage buildings and I'm not
sure
which page that was I haven't seen it in
the pages that we've passed
how much I'll just have to go back we
haven't done we've done Heritage and
that we've done heritage
they're coming back to that part so this
was the
um request by POC group yes okay you're
gonna come back
staff are going to do some more to do a
little bit more homework and come back
to us we're meeting they're meeting back
with us at 4 30. okay fine okay all
right but there's nothing else that you
need to cover while you're here
excellent so we're at UNR maybe we could
just have a stretch for a few minutes
awesome
uh five minutes stretch team
very generous
thanks
again
foreign
yeah
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
decent Rising
no we're
um we're going back to climate change
for a little bit
yes Nicola
oh Veronica I should say
is it the middle name that's your first
name
that's when I swore around that's what
her name was
mine's mine's mine's Daniel when I'm in
trouble not that Nikki's in trouble
um
Simon Europe
climate change oh we
I don't think Nikki will want to race it
oh today oh okay
Nikki you know
okay all right okay yes fine sorry
that's why I was calling you back to the
table
okay all right okay we're
we're there so let me just move forward
so we're at utilities and raiding now
but before we do that we've got some
Hello jurors
yeah yeah yeah
um
we'll deal with your uh papers we'll
deal with the papers first and then
we'll deal with the submission points
thereafter so
um first one is 6.9 Pages 21422 that's
resourcing for preparing for water
reform
staff submission to give you a second to
catch up there
thank you for making yourself available
Jared
[Music]
wow I actually haven't been able to find
it but I know which I know that look
it's the report regarding um three
Waters reform we've put in a budget to
be estimate we think it's prudent that
the council makes some provision
um the intention is to fund that over a
10-year term
um because it's not it would actually
have a fair impact if we just paid for
it as an operational expenditure and it
is a one-off and we also would look to
um and I think quite legitimately pass
that cost on as a three Waters debt if
we do end up going down that path to an
entity
um so look I'm happy to take questions
thank you questions of Jared
well whatever what I really want to know
is is it is it adequate or is this
pretty conservative
um I actually think for we've actually
said in there that it's this will get us
through to Christmas I think it's
conservative for that
um because
since we wrote that there's been a bit
more clarity around the Canterbury
Regional table so there's a much better
alignment between what
um the Canterbury mares or Canterbury
councils are expecting in conjunction
with my tahu and what we're expecting
um DIA to put out so that actually makes
our job a bit easier
so I think it's realistically I'd see
it'll it'll see us through for the full
Financial year but we'll keep the
council briefed as this goes
um and give you a good steer on whether
that's
um you know you know you'll get plenty
of advanced warning if we think we're
going to run out but I I really do think
that's that should be plenty for the at
least the full Financial year
cares about it
and just the question if it's mainly for
the consultation that is being required
from DIA had they offered to put up in
your funding
um
they haven't no we we have got no detail
on
um the what that's and we've tried to
request information on that we're not
expecting anything
um until when we get the package in July
but that may well be part of it there
may be some funding attached to that and
in which case you know that's that would
be be able to be applied there there is
some work we're already getting underway
so there's two current work streams that
we're getting the ball rolling on
um one of them is just actually modeling
an uplift scenario for for based on our
own ltp
um
figures and what I mean by uplifters you
know taking almost like a worst possible
case future for our district in terms of
what we think costs could get to so that
we can compare that with the DIA figures
and then also having a look in another
work streamers to start to have a look
at what would it mean for the rest of
the organization
um outside of three Waters the financial
impact how that might look so that we
we're actually on the front foot when we
get to July and and so where the cost
might start to get incurred on that is
where we're pulling staff out away from
their day job and we need to backfill
those
um and so that's not directly just
consultation some of it workers
investigations and so there's no
synergies to be gained by like combining
with hiranui considering we use the same
newspapers and same Publications and
things like that is there any synergies
definitely yeah we'll definitely be
looking at that okay so I just clarify
asdia when we had their workshop
three four weeks ago around this Alan
pregnant advisor hadn't even turned
their mind to this so they were going to
consider whether there would be funding
available for councils I've when I've
raised it with alumeral colleagues they
all look at me with surprise because
none of them are actually putting sort
of money aside in their budgets to do
this I think this is well personally
this is a really prudent approach to it
so it's the right thing to do but that's
that's the response from pregnant and
others Sam said to me when I was talking
to Sam Orton on Saturday that he thinks
that there may well be something that
comes about but everything's in flux
until we hear exactly there's so many
discussions going on no one will be
absolutely clear until we get the
package from government that we're
expecting in what June July aren't we
July definitely not June and no idea of
a date the um we're with it'll be driven
by effectively political announcements
uh the actual date
a bit too expire yep so
um moved by Council Atkins and seconded
Council Williams against Rick and Jewish
this week oh look I think this is
absolutely prudent I'm surprised to hear
you talk about other areas that aren't
putting things in I think you've got
your head in the sand if people don't
think um this is going to cost us
something no matter which way we go so
oh I think it's absolutely prudent that
we have this money there if we don't
spend it and the government comes up
with it all well and good
um but if they do come up with it at all
I'd also be very cautious about why we
should accept it from them as well
uh councilor Williams no I don't know
any further speakers
yep
this is really really important it's
probably one of the most important
things that we're going to have to do
for a long long time so we need to fight
this with everything we've got and give
it everything we've got to make sure
that we have the best case scenario and
that we survive
thank you uh Road of reply I'll put that
all those in favor please say all right
contrary to clear they're carried when
they're at 16 which is the three border
staff submission
if you wish to do is it Kelly leading
This Jared
just um what was said to staff really
just just keep it brief to the main
points we're we're making good progress
so I'm sure you'll be aware of that
thank you
well if we have to we have to but look
reality is we're tracking well hopefully
uh good afternoon so the purpose of this
report is
um just to uh seek a carryover a budget
for the three Waters Services management
budgets so each year we have a range of
different Asset Management projects what
we're planning on getting done next year
is substantially more than other years
because of changes coming in with new
drinking water standards and also tomato
arawi so you'll see under 1.3 of the
report that we've got some sizable
projects for doing our chlorination
assessment
um development of source risk a source
water risk management plans Reservoir
assessments and review of private water
supplies and there's a additional report
on our approach to private water
supplies and um
uh doing
um the sanitary assessments as well
effectively what we've gone through and
done is looked at our overall program
we've rationalized some projects we've
kept the
um important ones that we need to
undertake next year in we are actually
going to be a hundred and twenty
thousand over budget and if you look at
recommendation D you can see the list of
projects that we're actually delivering
and what it's proposed is that we carry
over a hundred and twenty thousand from
this Current financial year to next
financial year we will be under budget
substantially this year so we can
actually still deliver all of that
program of Works without impacting on
rates
happy to take any questions
thank you questions Council balance
Kelly I pay totally for my own septic
tank it's a private system why are we
spending so much money on private Waters
so it is the responsibility of the
landing
uh correct so the fifty thousand dollars
that we have
um in there is actually to do an
assessment to scope what is the problem
um how many people
um fall into which category so it's more
actually doing a stock take
um working out which ones Supply
themselves the example you gave they
have their own septic tank or they have
their own well they're classified as a
domestic supplier versus which ones are
actually now going to get captured by
the requirements of tomato arawi and
they will actually need to make sure
that they are registered and that they
meet the basic requirements that the
regulator is requiring so we won't
actually be doing any work as part of
that fifty thousand dollars to upgrade
their supplies or anything like that
it's more of a stock tape
and even talking to DIA their position
on this has been that even currently as
a local Authority he we have a
responsibility that's more your sanitary
assessments under section 125 of the
local government act so we've all really
got a responsibility now to make sure
whether it's a public or a private
Supply that our community has both
um Safe Water Supplies and also
Wastewater Disposal Systems is that what
others districts are doing as well
uh yes we um have met with Christchurch
City to see their approach to how they
are collecting information using a
slightly different approach but we're
learning from the work that they're
doing uh we're I'm aware that some of
the otago councils have already gone
through an exercise to scope
um you know how many private supplies
they have within their District
okay uh cancer Stewart
uh thank you the um water metering
investigations at 5K and Universal Water
metering assessment at 30k can you just
um elaborate on what the differences
between the two one question and second
do we have a a figure for a
district-wide water metering
is this going to be part of the
assessment or can you give us an idea if
in fact that becomes part and parcel of
reforms
um down
uh so the difference between the two
projects the water metering
investigations of five thousand dollar
figure is actually for the um metering
of our extraordinary users so our large
water users within the district uh the
thirty thousand dollars for the
universal order metering assessment so
that's effectively looking at what would
be so that's a specific study that's
being undertaken by pdu at the moment
and it's actually doing that assessment
of what would it cost to implement
Universal metering across the district
what would be the benefits and is there
a
benefit cost and actually going through
that process so that exercise was last
done back in about 2010 and it's
effectively
um updating that previous assessment
work
casablacking
favorite topics backflow prevention
um let's use a pays for the installation
so what does the 50 Grand cover
um in the in that graph
right
uh so backflow prevention is one of the
key parts of our water safety plans
um so that work is actually doing The
Upfront survey and classification of all
of the properties so determining whether
they've Fallen to the category of high
risk medium risk or low risk and it's
undertaking all of the administration to
actually you know liaise with those
property owners and make sure that
they're putting in the correct device at
the boundary
a few of the questions some Council
Williams should be to move seconded by
Council award to wish to speak
now it's good to see um and the budget
and Council Blackie I did ask about that
backflow one as well myself
and got got the right answers yes so um
but now a lot of these costs are
actually getting pushed onto us so we've
got no choice really
I'm sorry yes I forgot to note your name
down
um no it's all right no it wasn't there
yeah council do you wish to speak any
further speakers
no need for either reply unless you want
to reply to yourself I've put that all
those in favor please say aye contrary
to clear that Kerry thanks Kelly
um so we're at 6 11 now which is water
supply staff submission Colin
good afternoon
uh so this report as you'll be aware is
to cover off proposed changes to the
water supply budgets from the draft
long-term plan
um in preparation for the delivery of
the 2122 Capital program we've started
work on a number of the projects and as
part of doing this more detailed work
we've identified some projects where we
need additional budget to
uh to deliver the scope required
um the in total these required changes
are about four percent of the value of
next year's water supply Capital program
or about point four percent of the full
10-year program so although it would be
nice not to have any in the scheme of
things that's not a huge change
um
and it's really just a reflection of
trying to get onto these projects and
and going into their next level of
detail now which has picked out some of
these things
um that we need to
adjust so
um
uh that that's the bulk of the report is
seeking those adjustments to budgets the
only other note in the report
which was covered in the briefing
um to the utility voting committee is
that there are some items that we do
expect to change within the life of the
long-term plan
in particular with drink water standards
changes which aren't at a state yet that
they can be accurately
priced and included so
um it's just a note that there may be
other changes as the new standards are
released and come out
which we'll have to keep the council
briefed on as well
not happy to take any questions on that
thanks Colin any questions
sorry for you to move the recommendation
did you ever hear the question Jim
oh thanks Colin the capacity to deliver
these this extra budget is that an issue
at all uh no we're comfortable with the
capacity because we're not adding in
projects we've just um updated our cost
estimates and I think
the reason we've picked these up now is
because we are getting onto them now so
we're getting into that design stage
already so um we're confident with these
ones that we are already underway on
them and comfortable with them
okay so did you indicate Cancer Ward was
I know I said Council Duty seconded by
Council Williams
should speak
so once again thank you very much Colin
it's very very good report and
well keep up the good work
thank you Kelsey Williams
any further speakers
I'll put that all those in favor all
right contrary to clear that carried
so now on to 612 which is the drainage
staff submission so that's Kelly and
Jared
thanks Colin thank you
so that's reported to request uh five
changes to the drainage budgets uh
requests for additional budget for
planting at Pentecost system a that's
being constructed this financial year
just been completed additional budget
for coyev retaining wall as part of the
three books enhancement work
um also on the Northbrook between
Janelle to White Street for some
additional budget for retaining wool
hydro seeding
um and design work
and
um Norton place we're actually just
requesting
um budget for that project to be pushed
out
from the and that was part of a report
that went to the utilities and roading
committee so pushing out the
construction budget from 21 22 through
to 22 23 and finally Mill Road
stormwater management area in a Hoka no
changes are requested there but it's
just noting that
um
the construction estimate is currently
higher than the remaining construction
budget and we're just flagging that
we'll be looking at
um doing all we can to deliver that
project within the current budgets we've
got available
happy to take any questions thanks Kelly
any questions
so we have a recommendation somewhere
for you to move
I'll move it repeat a second that's
uh taking the drop just just briefly
thank you uh excellent work is always uh
I should have said the same when
um Colin was here as well we really
appreciate what you and the team do it's
excellent work and
um yes it's a very big work program and
Jim is right to observe that before
there's a lot going on so just want to
acknowledge that as well as all the
three Waters work that's going on too so
thank you Kelly for that
um Robbie do you wish to get to Brian
any few of the speakers I'll put the
recommendation all those in favor all
right contrary to clear that carriage
waste water so again Kelly yeah so the
Wastewater staff submission is
requesting three changes
um to the ocean outfall
um kaiapoi renewals budgets in kaiapoi
wastewater treatment plant planting so
in terms of the ocean outfall there was
a forty thousand dollar budget next year
for PLC replacement
um that we now have determined we no
longer require so we're asking for that
budget to be removed
um
the kaiapoi renewals has got um a
substantial change so we did actually
have budget in outer years for the con
replacement of the Chapman Place Rising
main now that is on the alignment of the
storm water pipe for the shovel ready
project uh so what we're asking for is
for Budget to be brought forward for
that but also for additional budget
um so we the the total cost is um higher
than what we had in the budget
um the net effect of that is
um it doesn't have an impact on rates
because the Eastern districts has a
surplus within the renewals fund so
effectively the um replacement of The
Works will be undertaken as part of the
um will be funded from the renewals fund
uh the final thing to note is um kaiapoi
wastewater treatment plant planting you
may be aware we're looking at the forest
or the the Pines planted around the
outsides of the or the Western Northern
and Eastern sides of the treatment plant
in coming up with a strategy for uh
taking those harvesting those trees and
then also replanting those
um what we've asked for is
um a budget within the
yeah it was yeah
I'm gonna need to get that thing turned
off I'm sick of it
22 23 Financial year uh so that will
actually mean that we're going to spend
next financial year just planning out
our strategy for that so we're getting
some advice from forestry Consultants at
the moment in terms of how we
potentially can stage that there's a
number of different things here that we
need to juggle with regards to impact on
adjacent Property Owners Midge
management as well as making sure we get
the um the the best return for the the
trees that are within that area
so happy to take any questions
well it's sort of covered off where you
think I'm sure you look at me
given the problems we had last time when
we removed the trees totally around with
smell and wind and so on please tell me
you're not looking at moving the trees
in totality before you plant
we're getting advice on that at the
moment so what we're meeting with the
forestry consultant on is a two-stage
approach where we're actually
um on the western boundary which is
probably the boundary of most concern
there's a 80 meter width of trees and
we're proposing at the moment to take it
um down in two stages so there will
always be at least a 40 meter barrier of
existing trees here but we're giving
advice on that we will actually bring a
report to utilities and routing
committee once we
um have a strategy for um the removal of
trees at the kaiapoi wastewater
treatment plant as well as the proposed
planting as well so can I suggest you
get some advice from the the Western
people who live down that area when they
were removed last time they'll tell you
along Fury Road
okay
gas award
my question exactly the same as um
councilor Atkinson but you know I can
tell you that pittosporum is a Natives
and leafy all year round and quick
growing so you know they might be a good
a good option yes
I'll take yeah yeah I think yeah I think
have you considered that as an option
thank you sorry council meeting so I
hope it's a question it is a question
um so just just with regard to the tree
removal you did mention um you kind of
touched on I was about to ask you
um a rate of return for those trees
um now I see that we've got a proposed
new budget of fifty thousand dollars for
landscape planting there
um do you have any kind of idea of what
kind of return that we might get for the
the mature trees as they're harvested or
does it depend on the the bulk amount
that we remove at a time
uh so that's part of what we're getting
advice on um the preliminary advice that
we've got and we're working with our
property team on this is that the
kaiapoi wastewater treatment plant there
are areas of trees that are mature now
ready for Harvest and that they would
get a return from but um there are areas
like along the eastern boundary where
effectively the the low quality trees
and we wouldn't get much of a return
from from those trees
um so the um
budget that we've got in there is for
planting we are hopeful that the actual
removal operation would be cost neutral
or hopefully would be a slight return in
our favor
foreign
seconded by councilor Ward
um I could use to same thing
okay Council Ward
okay fifth speakers
I just hope we um do look after the
neighbors and get the um
petosporums hopefully or something like
that growing first before we actually
take them all out and make a problem for
ourselves because
um it was originally what's been was
proposed I understand and I think it's
very important to look after our
community when we do this type of
scenario
you look very quickly I think I alluded
two of my questioning but certainly
neighbors around there remember the last
time the trees were moved from there and
I live not too far away from there
myself plus we now have
um uh Beech Grove that wasn't there
before so can I suggest if you remove
the trees and there is an easterly wind
it's not rocket science we know which
way the smell of the uh of the plants
gonna go and we know exactly what's
going to happen with the community if
indeed they do get that smell
through the speakers rather replied
Council meetings just simply Echo the
concerns of my fellow counselors that
yes I think some some
um earlier planting of some fast-growing
species to start to mitigate the issues
with smell coming from the removal of
those trees would be prudent
okay so I'm going to put recommendation
now all those in favor eye contrary to
clear their Carriage we're there at 6.14
water and Sanitary Service assessment
Kelly
cool
so this report aligns with the fifty
thousand dollars that I referred to
about four reports ago this effectively
sets out the approach that we plan to
take in terms of spending
um that money
um so here's Sophie
straight up so
you can aim all of the curly Christians
at Sophie
um
so effectively this sets out a number of
different options in terms of how we
actually approach and resources and what
we're recommending is uh that it's
option two which is a fifty thousand
dollar budget
where effectively we're going to be um
uh using a in-house team we may have
contracted staff to um help deliver this
project uh so happy to take any
questions
um or Sophie or answer any as well
there's no trouble any questions
moved by Council Atkinson seconded by
councilor Blakey wish to speak
any further speakers what they had all
those in favor I contrary to care that
Carriage excellent
easiest questions you faced thank you
we're now at solid Solid Waste um just a
question in terms of the order of the
agenda did you want to do all of the UNR
well I was going to do all the whites
sorry do these Pages first
um yeah there isn't many hold on well
we've only got we've only got uh kitties
papers doing now and then that's all
your papers done apart from
if we just finish these now yeah and
then we'll be on to submission points
yeah
so um Kitty please
welcome by the way
I'm presuming I'm not actually covering
much off I'm not even going to read
through my
um
my summary which is quite quite long so
I'll just assume you have read the paper
and how do you take questions it's it's
fine if there's any main points you want
to raise it's no trouble but we have
read it all so all good
um any questions
there's a recommendation of someone
moved by accounts Brian seconded by
count Savannah
speak
um any further speakers I'll put the
recommendation all those in favor all
right country Carriage oh that's the
easiest year you've here to eat really
um okay excellent thanks Kitty
um we're now at 6.16 Ravenswood Park and
Ride Land pictures
so let's jump in
Pokemon oh thank you this feels like
roading speed dating
I didn't know there was such a thing but
clearly there is we've missed out teams
yeah right um so just to keep this very
brief this report is asking that budget
which we had in our annual I surround
the long-term plan for property purchase
and Ravenswood of four hundred thousand
dollars be moved out a year as we've got
some work to do first to identify a site
I'm happy to take any questions
thank you any questions counts about us
this very quickly I noticed that these
stages are being released much more
quickly than anticipated previously will
that have any impact on if we miss out
if we if we're running out of time
to get Space
um no I don't think so we're really
started those discussions with
developers and I think need to look
slightly wider at the wood end area to
make sure we are getting an appropriate
site so okay
um food thank you further questions
moved to counts the balance seconded by
councilor Ward
yeah Savannahs just to say delighted I'm
just delighted to see it start pushing a
budget out thank you
okay Cass award
okay any further speakers I'll put the
recommendation all those in favor I
can't treat to clear that Carriage now
it's 6.17 which is you join as well I
think you and Kelly isn't it so
this is belgrave development
hi Kelly hello thank you
um so these projects that are part of
this report have come about from ongoing
discussions with the developer as we've
kind of progressed what they're looking
to do and how that fits in with the
structure plan so the timing of us
getting an understanding of what we are
looking to do here wasn't such that it
could be included in the long-term plan
um so the value of the works has
triggered a special consultative process
but the majority of the works are funded
through development contributions rather
than rates
we have started working with the policy
team the comms team in governance to get
this process
I guess mapped out pending approval here
and we will be looking to bring a
further report to select a hearings
panel if you um approve us commencing
with the SCP
um with that I'll try and re-roof and
take any questions any questions against
the walls further back outside
just a quick question I know there's a
house at the end of mcphail Avenue and
on Burger Avenue is that required as
part of the roundabout and as that
needed to be
um needed to be probably just need to be
careful about the answer that question I
would say it's all right in the public
Arena yeah yeah I I agree
um that that house is in the alignment
of the road and as part of our
consideration for that round today thank
you uh Council ballot
just a process question probably more
for Jared actually I know you've got
circulates this report to the
ringeration community board is there any
reason why this wasn't brought to the
ringer issue community board for input
about the local area first
um the yeah I suppose there's a couple
of reasons one is the rangiora community
board have been consulted
um in the past about the structure
planning for this area
this report specifically relates to
development contributions and we
normally don't
go and consult the community board
um where
in relation to development contributions
the other the other thing is this has
happened data at pace so we've been in
um Kelly Joanne and I are in ongoing and
active discussions with the major
developer in this area and this has been
put in at the last minute
um to and it did miss the um the ltp
consultation so look but you raise a
good point we as this progresses we
should be updating And discussing with
and getting input from the community
board some of the areas will be the
treatment of copenberger Ave I know
that's an area that's quite important
linkages through to the sports facility
so yeah it's a it's a it's a good
reminder for us that we should be making
a point of trying to be proactive in
terms of Engagement with the community
board
um any further questions
you're prepared to move accounts award
uh seconded by
seated by cancer ballot we should just
speak Council Ward thank you I've
noticed coming out of McFarland I choose
that
um routes now from from below Northbrook
Road to go East to Wood end as opposed
to going down and trying to get turned
right from five Crossroads and it's very
very busy and there's so much traffic
there so roundabout is a really good
um a really good option in them as well
and I thoroughly support this resolution
thank you cares about it
and I'm really happy to see this it's a
common sense report I've actually seen
quite a few Nemesis at that intersection
that area is getting busier and we are
in desperate need of some of that
subdivision so it's very good to see
that this is progressing quite fast
thank you
okay since we've been secreted any
further speakers
if you wish to respond to anything the
council Awards
good thank you okay
what the recommendation is in favor I
contrary to clear that carried right so
we now come to the page one five one
for two minutes and then we'll break for
afternoon tea
so um Jared have you got the pages there
as we go through sorry we we we're
pulling it up and just giving you a
moment to keep thank you just jumping
from one
um
to the other so it's ratings have Joanne
wants to be here she doesn't have to be
but
you can have a bit more of us than speed
dating if you like
not that I've ever done that actually
but apparently it's a lot of fun
[Laughter]
never done it
that's all right sure people out there
have a sense of humor all right all
right got the uh yeah so we we're just
going to move through these now but I
just wanted to make sure you were there
with us so what page are you on uh one
five one okay so
uh one planet five one and the white
page in our book
okay so one five one no okay
one five two
one five three
one five four
I think um we just need to add in here
in the recommendation to submitters
that the bypass was added through the
area through the rltp
the other day so and also the award The
Wider narrative that there's been
advocacy to the minister we've got the
nzta officials to visit so there's a
story there that could be bolstered
would be appreciated
one five six
six one five seven
we got the figures for Park and Ride yet
yeah we did circulate the information
that we did have can we add these into
these answers this one here is asking
about park and ride it would be good if
we did add what those figures are in
there yeah I'll have a look at what came
yeah that'd be great
I don't think so at the moment because
it's I guess it's trying to paint the
full picture with the figures and
they're only giving us a little space
I think it's a good point though when we
do know what they are we should because
there's a lot of interest in it so
uh one five eight
one five nine
160.
161. you so 160 is that one six one
I'm trying to see what recommendation
we're actually going with
um
um it's option one option two we're not
actually saying any
other than what utilities and writing
has has already said so I'm assuming
we're sticking with with that utilities
and writing
so I wasn't saying here in the Staffing
admission is
correct so we are um so we need to make
that much more clear I agree that it's
confused well spotted thank you
one six one one six two
one six three
one six four
one six five when we're talking about
the walking and cycling Network plane
can we can we say who's been involved in
that because there's quite a stakeholder
group isn't there
be helpful just to spell that out a bit
more
one six
six
six one six seven
one six eight
one six nine
170. so with this one here
um
we hit a submitter come and speak to us
about this here I wonder if it's a an
opportunity
um that we should look at this location
and I wonder if our staff could look at
what the options are and in report to
our community board and also Vector
Council
whether there's any minor safety
opportunities for the Syria that was
raised quite strongly at the house and
and I've noticed on the Community
um Facebook pages that's been subject to
quite a bit of discussion so
I think if we could call for a report on
that and if that could be included in
there that would be helpful
so I think what I had suggested with
that one is that it would be considered
against and prioritized with the other
projects within the walking and cycling
plan
um
I guess there's gonna have to be those
trade-offs for where where and when we
prioritize works yeah I don't disagree
with that but it's a specific issue
locally it's about kids and that they've
raised and road safety I I think it can
feed into that exercise but calling for
report
um I think would be a to obtained within
the week program would be appreciated
and worked with the board and come back
to council
um custom
you also possibly with the um like the
community team and people like there
that talk about the option of doing it
as a shared project with the community
because that's how we're cheap wood into
wooden Beach so it doesn't have to be
all Council funded because if it doesn't
meet the high priority projects is what
I'm sort of thinking yeah I'm just not
aware whether there's a community group
out there that would drive that project
or not well
there actually could be there's a really
strong feeling about it so perhaps
Lincoln with Nikki as well she's pretty
well schooled with who's out there okay
um cancer Duty
um with this one would that go through
to Road Safety as well because we've got
a meeting next month
because it's a with tram Road and things
like that
well we haven't quite got to that page
yet so that's page so this is um Karen
Hardy's at the same one is it yeah it is
this is the shared pass from tram Road
yep okay
this is a petition she's put forward
okay
all right yeah Nikki I think it's
important to note that when it comes to
what's being requested by by Mrs Hardy
um it it's it is a safety issue and the
school's catchment actually
um
goes out into into that wider area which
the children have no choice but to hit
100K roads to get into into school
otherwise they have to get in a car
which of course we all know Swannanoa
has been having has had historically I
mean has has had historic issues with um
cars vehicle safety bus safety
um talking about their their speed
limits and whatnot it would be great to
take cars off the road around that
pickup drop-off Zone and the only way to
do that is to get people taking active
transport and right now there just isn't
a safe option for that and there's a
huge Groundswell of people really
willing to to fight for that there was a
lot of disappointment from one of our
our community board member that was put
on that Cycling group whenever she found
that basically the strategy was really
only meant in her words for urban people
and um our rural areas do actually need
to have some some consideration in this
because it's not just a recreational
thing but it's also or a safety matter
so if we can't drop the speed limit in
front of a school that's on 100K Zone
then perhaps we can actually help them
out by by adding something
um that makes it safer for kids to get
to school on a bike
I think I think this could be a really
positive discussion if we have it right
so we could focus as we've talked our
viewer happy with that direction
okay uh one seven one
uh one seven two
one seven three
one seven four
yes
talked about in here
this is probably part of the wider
kaiapoi to wooden discussion that has
come up in a lot of submissions
um but it talks about assessing rude
options between carpool and woodend and
it talks about the broad Workshop
kaiapoi tuahui I just wonder why Woody
and sifton isn't involved in that
conversation if it's a kite with a
wooden discussion
well so
apologies I can update it because they
have it they've all been involved yeah
yeah because I mean it's because this
submission was particularly prominent
board it was talking about the paper
Road in the kaiapoi part but the
intention was to take it right through
to woodend I'm thinking yeah sorry I'd
written the response um because I think
that came via Oh Martin obviously yeah
I guess it's just if we look at from if
we're looking the perspective of what in
Sefton may be but that route is not
suitable because it's not a direct route
to the school
um so this I just want to make sure that
both ends were covered
okay
um 175
yeah
I'm happy with what's yes it's good good
job yeah it does good job
one one seven six
one seven seven now this one here
um
we have since discovered there is going
to be a recommendation on a speed review
on an Oxford so
from what we discussed yesterday at
management it was to be added in and
that picks up the community board
discussion recently so can we add that
in and I I would suggest that the
weeding probably needs to be
reconsidered as a consequence of that it
was quite a big answer if we're
reviewing the speed limit that's
actually all they're asking it's what
they want so we could reduce that answer
um because we're reviewing it we're not
guaranteeing that it'll all go to where
they want it to be but we're reviewing
the speed limit yeah
thank you
just
um
just making sure you didn't have any
comments on the Dark Skies one which was
the one just before no we were happy
with this but no that's right I thought
so what we're doing is we're just
flicking the pages and if people have
used different they'll let me know
um
yep
so
let me subject to
it should then be subject to Lane
transport or the whakataki um
funding as well rather than the cassette
sitting present with her with us with
new footpaths without Government funding
on it maturity I agree we should make
that clarification
would be subject to
um
thank you
that's what so we put 450 in there
didn't we and it was subject too yes we
did make that clear at the time I'm
pretty sure we did yeah I would have to
go and back and check the wording but
yes it may well have been
but does it will let impact on the
delivery of the this coming year because
it's what we
um if we if we weren't successful in
gaining funding I guess it would need to
be a report back to council for a
decision on how you wanted to proceed
okay
I just just couldn't remember exactly
what we had resolved in that regard
so I can hear cancer
sorry did you have a question
I don't know what the work was that was
going on at the moment
so we're upgrade isn't it yeah okay so
there's this um the current work this is
um
we're doing three things at once uh
water sewer
and the
um traffic calming measures associated
with the speed limit is one package of
work all right so yes so one eight one
um 184
um just wonder if the big end of that is
right as such the upgraded to Pito Road
should be carried
carried at a time and development codes
and the writing Financial contributions
are paid we think we want is it the way
we want to express that
we could look at
um trying to package that a little bit
better but we do need to yeah I would
use things like consideration of
contributions as well right yeah I'm
sure you'll massage that thank you
uh one eight five I think we should yep
sorry you go yep
I just wanted to clarify what budget we
have in the 10-year plan for the ohaka
Road Island Road intersection
in terms of the program do we have a
placeholder for that
so for Ireland ohoka for around about
all traffic lights
yes yeah we do have a budget
um 1.3 million from memory I'm just
trying to think sorry on the
it is in the program and where it is and
we're but we're just subject obviously
subject to funding from work sorry
what's this one eight four the bottom of
185 yeah you've just put in there that
you are it's a hype of establishing
Innovations over the page but it said
it's a high priority in other things but
it doesn't say there's any funding in
the 10-year plan
any placeholder budget for it
okay I can put the year in just yeah a
bit more on that thank you so just back
at one eight thank you guess about it
185 and the top of 185 in the Box could
we also add in um around the foot path
as well and that
add back to the submitter I'm putting
what we've got to put a foot path in
there as well subject to funding
funding is councilor um Williams
mentioned before
okay we're at South sir 186. we're going
to have a break now we're at South Brook
Road enhancements
um quarter of a net yes
with the um well we're going to come
back to that giant are you I'm going to
call the break now because all right
well I was trying to find a logical
break point there's not one so
um let's let's do now and back at 20
past
um
three past four okay
yeah
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
this one
[Music]
foreign
we're going to whip through some writing
and I did say that our other staff to
come back about half past four so we'll
try and finish the writing submissions
and then we'll move on to
back to the historic
um well the PLC submission okay
um did you want to do the three water
submissions why don't we just do that
after the writing uh yes well we're just
going to keep running through we're
going to finish the whole lot today
hopefully
all right so we're at Southbrook parade
enhancements now so that's Rangers
community board
es Council you're going to ask a
question yes or a point did you have a
correction
[Music]
with the South Rock Road enhancements
should we be mentioning this um that
we're looking at other options by an
Eastern bypass to sort of alleviate that
there's something that we're underway
with trying to resolve this issue why
don't we just add in the words I was
suggesting gonna suggest here at the
working part that there's a working
party and at the board chair is included
also around the signalized Crossing in
the Eastern bypass has been mentioned so
it answers the board's direct questions
there okay is it okay with you Council
Ward
okay any other all right
so
um
we're at uh 1 8h
I think we can add any of those points
raised before around what ends raised
earlier just to add those back and
they're working with the nzta officials
to see the improvements delivered fast
for the bypass the rltp has asked for
the bypass to be bought out of horizon
projects or whatever the terminology was
all right
um
one uh eight nine
do you think we should also put in here
and our answer that we have education on
trim Road improvements with nzta
particularly at the bridge that picks up
that what's the lady's name uh Nikki
that we
so else it's not Elsa but the lady that
met with us last year
daughter had the accident
Tina Dudley yeah so yeah
okay uh 190
191 I just are there response could we
sort of indicate to uh Mr spark thinking
thanking him for his willingness to work
with the council because I thought it
was a really good offer from him
just to
um
192.
[Music]
um
I know we're waiting for ecan to come
back to us about the Timaru trial but
had we thought about doing some sort of
Investigation on about ourselves in
terms of intra-town connectivity because
that's been raised in the Youth Forum
it's been raised in elderly persons
Forum it's something that if we we may
not get anything from again for years so
is there a possibility of investigating
that more closely ourselves
um well through through the my way my
understanding through staff will create
from wrong but they were looking to
trial it in other locations within
um the greater Christchurch area and
they haven't decided I know and they
sell ones put their hand up for it
because but it would be um really good
if we could also put our hand up for
that trial because that's effectively
what it is it's kind of a more on-demand
service
um I was just going to say we do have
the Mini Bus
trust I think Tony also offer a does
provide a service and does get some ecan
support I know they have trouble getting
drivers yeah at times
yeah
um we do obviously have the new bus
services even the Pegasus to rangiora
and I understand even patronage on that
has been very low
um so that will continue to be a bit of
an ongoing going challenge for us
but the certainly the my way trial if
that's possible our district could be
involved in that furthering that that
would be I think a really good outcome
hmm
okay well if we could look into that uh
that would this is an action point that
would be really good
uh 193
194.
excuse me 196.
story but I think the actual answer
doesn't match the question on the
roundabout at Lehman's in Oxford Road
the answer talks about fernside flext
and skew bridge but they're actually
talking about Main Road Oxford Road and
Layman's Road outside the vet center
and they're talking about around about
there so the answer doesn't match
the question
um I was I guess trying to see a little
bit of a saying in terms of The Wider
context of what we're looking at and
under Note 5 head put that we have
around about planned there in 25 26.
so sorry that was just trying to see a
little bit of content yeah yeah so it's
good answer yeah no just it's a good
answer yeah good yeah when you read it I
I read it through it I thought it's all
talking about skew Bridge
197.
198.
um
we're into three Waters now so
you can take team off and speed dating
there
[Laughter]
come come again
all right
um three Waters so uh 200 just wondered
um can we please
um add to this that we strongly
submitted on this and presented to the
select committee on this topic around
the three the the water services bill
um and and if even if you want to
summarize some of our submission points
on it but we've got a good answer in
that space
um
uh what 201
-202
uh 203 we probably want to add in our
response back here that we are
looking at a district ride the
district-wide rating review will
consider this because that's that's to
come up on the next financial year so
okay
now we did I did signal to the residents
when they were here that we would uh
have a uh would would come out and have
another catch up with them so can we
include that in their answer and I guess
Jared it's about Denise just working
that through with governance around
setting up that time but
we did offer that to them at the time
that we'd be happy to come back out and
catch up around their issues or the
remaining meters they wanted to us to
see
to 11.
212.
yes
you turn your microphone on please thank
you to 11. I know we removed the Culvert
back in 1996. presumably for a
district-wide benefit
in terms of flooding it was restricting
flow but now we're saying it's a private
issue if you want to put the Culvert
back I just wondered if that seemed Fair
the Culvert was removed by Council back
in 1996 because it was undersized and
was causing an adverse effect on the
road
so they were consulted at the time and
they agreed to the removal of the
Culvert
and it's only been in recent years that
they have because we've done other works
in neighboring properties Upstream and
they are now asking for Council to fund
the rep will fund a new Culvert to one
of their Lots so they do actually have a
a culvert beer to access one of the a
lot so it's two neighboring lots that
they actually own
um our understanding is they actually
want to
develop the the second lot and so
they're you know just looking at whether
Council would fund that for them
uh Cass Williams
I put the undersized cover and need more
of the council originally
was it one of their culverts or one of
ours
which one we removed I'm not 100 sure on
that
um I believe it was
um
a private Crossing that was installed
whether we provided advice on the sizing
of it
um at the point at that point in time
when it was removed
um we made it clear to them that they
would be responsible for for reinstating
a um a culvert or a Bridge Crossing
okay uh to eleven
to twelve
213.
tag team back in
then it's back so
just me just just for my own General and
I don't know how this how people will
feel about this but in reply to the
Rooney this year
in totality I just wonder whether we
have it um translated into the rail to
get back to them there's a gesture of
good oh that's a good idea
that's possible
oh it's it's
doing both well let's see what's
possible but it's a good suggestion yeah
look we'd have to look at how
achievable that is but yes yes
at least at least the grating Parts at
the very least and the ending Parts but
if the pieces can be done there that
would be would be good
thank you good suggestion
uh 215
216.
217.
218.
219.
yes
um Templeton group Once A Way Forward
has been agreed to a plan for vesting
the lake will be required I don't like
that wording the vesting the plan for
vesting the lake will be required when
the situation has been resolved not once
a Way Forward has been agreed to
yeah just to point just to make that
crystal clear that we're not we're not
taking that thing over until it's fixed
okay
um yeah look we'll probably won't be
quite as crystal clear as you would like
um but I understand the intent that
you're you've you've got there
okay uh two two three
um I think that's that's you done you're
right isn't it
uh District plan
I think the rest is to strip playing
isn't it
thank you
well thank you
thank you and team
good work
probably the easiest budget round you've
been through really
and this is there's nothing else to
cover in yours
the development contribution submission
yeah yeah there is District development
measure here
[Music]
um
I think that's more Tracy or Trevor's
area
just we can just double check that if
you like
I think I think that's I think that's it
okay
I've just double checking quickly
220 was development contributions I
think so yep it's just double check
there
yep so it's done thank you thanks team
cheers you can come tomorrow if you like
[Laughter]
um
so should we revisit the topic that
we're away are you ready to do this now
if you ever if you could just wait
um let me just put a flag in the page
where I need to
okay
so
all right so we're um back on pages
67 and 68.
hey it seems like a lifetime ago
welcome back we should talk we should
tie Grant
isn't it Thai day
well you've succeeded there we are all
right so what did you find out team
we had a couple of conversations with a
few people and there is um
more than the 84 currently in the budget
but there is money which has already
been allocated um to some ecology-based
projects which hasn't been dished out
yet so the 84 as we were sitting at the
moment with their money which has
already been allocated to those other
projects
so that when you say more than 84 what's
the totality it was around 140 000 in
the budget at the moment
I don't have a list of the projects at
the moment but that information came
from Gina who's the one that's actually
managing their fund at the moment
the ones that were approved as part of
the last round of um of that group
making those um approvals for Ecology
funds so there's 84 000 left there
hasn't been allocated
and has seen it was the intense to what
we discussed that that'd be split
uh so the intention was that that would
be
um split next year
um with
um half of it going into the
um Heritage fund and half of it going
into the biodiversity
um fund and in the biodiversity fund
would grow as was explained by Grant up
until it gets to around that hundred
thousand in year 10 with
um I believe it was the 15 000 remaining
to be added to the historical fund every
single year so that does build up again
as well so the 15K when does that get
added
remaining in the budget
um as was already always there
so that that will go to the historical
fund so that'll have 42 000 next year
and then it'll have well sorry to have
42 is the carryover and then an extra 15
added and then an extra 15 year on year
after that and what's the the status of
the ecological fund well that sorry all
the the split fund well they'd also have
funds added to it as well it's 42 and is
that an extra 15. no so Russia said next
year next year it's hell there's nothing
next year
year two and its age and then it
progressively goes to 15.
so then it starts to build up on that
basis okay so there's 42 in the history
in the Heritage fund plus 15 next year
and 15. it's a year out in to go up by
15 every year is that right uh
apparently it's not 15 next year it's
nice next year and then 15 15. so is
this the heritage heritage fund it goes
so it's eight then to 15 and the same
with the ecological no the ecological
one goes up at a much faster rate so the
next year there's nothing additional for
the ecological one okay but then it goes
up quite significantly up until it
reaches around
um well it was 100 but it's been CPI
adjusted so the budget looks like around
116 or something in year 10 of the
long-term plan at the moment so the
question is whether we add to that fund
to top the fund up so we had a little
bit of a discussion with Matt bacon
around
um the the bnz building specifically in
terms of what what I guess the the two
options we saw being on the table one
option is to specifically grant money to
for the bnz building if that's what
council wants to do because they're
identifying that that's where they want
the money to go the other option is to
increase the Heritage fund but in
increasing the Heritage fund you would
be on understanding that the reason
you're doing that is because you want
the bnz building to be judged on its
merits against other buildings in a
contestable process correct
um alongside those other buildings and
you're providing extra money to reflect
the fact that there's that building but
there's also other buildings which need
to be assessed as opposed to putting the
money in into that Heritage fund with
the intention that it would go to the
bnz because that seems like it but we
were in workshop last time so I'll do it
again but that's personally what I feel
comfortable about doing the later Parts
is adding to it but on the condition
that it's contestable because it's not
fair to other groups otherwise I have a
great deal of sympathy for this but it
would just need to stack up against
other applications that go on that's and
I'm quite I don't know how the recipe
feel for them quite happy to support
Phillips
topping mate found out was it 58 000 was
that is it what you were supervising I
didn't actually provide a figure
uh well I thought I thought you'd
propose to to talk
oh okay I can't remember what it was now
yeah okay
yeah sure sure well it's sort of
Workshop so let's it's easier that way
before we get into recommendations
I'll come to you soon
um just asking time frame though if we
if we decide today
to top it up when is the next
application round and how long is it
going to take and what time frame is the
bnz because the bnz we've been waiting
for ages how long will it be before the
bnz people have an answer
so there's no application around it such
people can apply all the time
occasionally we go out and do some
advertising and call for applications
just to sort of let people know again
um I just asked Simon basically that
same question but mine was more around
the timing of the bnz building and
whether there was time pressures
associated with that
um the beans are building's already
under construction and as long as they
were aware of the fact that there was a
contestable process that they could
apply for
um they could apply for it now being
that there's money sitting there now but
they can also apply after after July as
well so the time frame is not
um can't be retrospective
yes I understand yeah
the work is currently underway
so if it doesn't meet the criteria
within that fund of effect then
um
yeah well anyway
um it's a good point though um
okay uh Council Stewart
that was my question because what has
happened
um in the period after the Quake was we
left
um we left applications to the funds
both funds the vegetation and and the
building fund to build up until we had a
few and then we had a hearing and there
were a number that were retrospective
because of that process and the question
is now is is
um because Jed and Mark came for a grant
and they were also advised that they
could apply
um to the fund and I suggested that they
do apply to the fund and as soon as we
get an application we can have a hearing
or evaluate it so I mean that's my
understanding
um that and really they have to do the
work put the receipts in and then they
get refunded they they apply they can
apply currently doing the work but we've
got to see the work they don't get the
money in advance of doing the work
um so I mean I would be
um Keen that we if the if the council
here wants to
um consider an application to the fund
that I know that they've got
um I've talked about that with Chris
last week that they've actually been
sent an application to the fund that
they fill it out and then we we
reconvene a panel which we'll usually do
and considerate if we're going to wait
until we have like we did before
you know 10 applications then they're
going to be long through their process
along through the well Council are
concern was saying that there are a
couple of years in terms of that project
it's a big job it's not going to be done
in two seconds so
um is there any is anyone against
topping the fund up is there anyone
opposed to doing it and the suggestion
on the table before was around 60 000 is
that is that where is there comfort in
doing that
let's do it
so we'll need a recommendation to the
so let's
um
well it's approves uh I'm just looking
here at our recommendation it's
effectively
um
approves approves uh
an additional sixty thousand dollars
uh to be able to to be applied to the
council's heritage
biodiversity and ecological fund
um that's effectively what we need to do
and but but on the condition that it's
not being split off to the other fund
um on the two funds it's it's the sixty
thousand to the to the Heritage fund is
that the correct term it's just the
Heritage fund isn't it
is that like is it
yeah
what's the effect on the right hand
crease by doing six things
so that will be
point one so puts us up to 2.3 is that
chief
oh
[Laughter]
sorry uh it's been a long day
is there comfort in there are we
I just wondered Mr me or it doesn't
necessarily have to be topped up to a
hundred
because the other number tossed around
was fifty thousand and if we topped it
up to a little over there it would only
be eight or ten thousand dollars
at this point
it would utilize the whole fund and
that's the concern you know it's just
proposing an amount here is there
comfort in that
okay
so it's a one-off Adrian if we captured
that I'll need a second for that so we
got just for clarity let's just bring
that back
yep
for 21 22.
okay so it's seconded by cancer Duty uh
no I think there's been a few discussion
on this it's a Heritage one building but
it's really important that this fund is
it whilst it's every encouragement for
this particular project to go in there
but I think it's really important that
it is contestable and it's considered in
that criteria because it's what it needs
to be to be fair to everyone
um
um Council Duty
I'm happy with it but like like you've
said it must be contestable
if you're the speakers
well the one two three four wouldn't be
needed
no
so it's it's a it's a different it's a
completely different uh Amendment
far out
but they went they weren't in they were
intend to start with so um well they
were because we moved them earlier uh
moved um on block so let's uh
um
so that's the amendment uh any further
speakers
I'll put the amendment all those in
favor please say aye country
to clear that carry thanks team
nice to see you um do come again
all right so we're now
um
okay we're now at um District plane
District development so Trevor
Trevor and the angel Tracy
oh sorry it's uh two two four
so we've got
um you've got no oh sorry firstly we'll
deal with
um
uh 6.1 H Pages three two three to three
three two
so that's the Christchurch greater
Christchurch partnership funding for
spatial planning
Trevor uh thank you Mr Mia uh rather um
virtuously Council or subject to a
briefing yesterday from members of the
greater Christchurch partnership I think
most of you were at that uh that was by
Anna elfek and independent chair Jim
Palmer in that briefing uh those guys
ran through
um the background to the 2050 project in
terms of the lofty visions that are
sought to be achieved talked about the
spatial planning process underway and it
also talked about mass reper transit as
well so much of those Concepts that you
would have heard yesterday uh covered in
this report so I won't um uh go over
those again what I have done for your
benefit in this report is just to
outline I guess sort of three key
funding areas in recent times regarding
those projects one is some monies that
have already been committed to pull the
2050 project which is underway at the
moment the second is
being able to fund some spatial planning
uh contributions out of existing budget
so that's been achieved out of the
existing uh budgets over the next two
years it does exhaust those budgets to
um and leave very little Headroom left
in their budget but nonetheless we can
fund it through those budgets at this
stage and the third part is really
around the resource needed to contribute
to the spatial planning project over the
next two years and potentially Beyond as
its actions and tasks become more
visible and there's been a lot of uh
sizing work done on the scope of the
project the inputs required and
effectively out of that out of that work
which was independently assessed by RCP
resource coordination Partnerships
for the partnership is that the council
needs to on average provide a couple of
Staff over the course of the next couple
of years to that project we currently
have the equivalent of one staff member
or just under
comprising part of Cameron Woods time
and hiker down his time and they both
started on that project but the purpose
of this report is to seek funding for an
additional staff member to contribute to
that project the suggestion here is that
it is a fixed term
uh appointment
for two years and the funding would be
for that two-year period
okay any questions I think that's all
really clear from yesterday Council
Barnett
Trevor
um you mentioned it being a fixed term
but noting that there's been difficulty
finding planning staff how attractive is
that likely to be on the current market
and my personal view is it makes it a
little bit more difficult
um it's already a difficult environment
and I think we've talked before that if
we do need to cast The Net wide
you know sometimes a fixed term contract
campus some challenges for example a
family person who needs to move their
family for example to the district
um
nonetheless I think we can use our HR
department to ensure that the position
is deemed to be attractive and indeed
the job itself is quite unique for
Canterbury at the stage
right
so there's a any further questions
there's a recommendations some appear to
move move by Council Atkinson seconded
by our second oh sorry Council meetings
you can see that
Council Atkinson do you speak cancer
meetings
it's really important work thanks team
good report okay further speakers I'll
put the recommendation all those in
favor I contrary to clear their carried
foreign
so that's that one there so if we just
move through the submission papers now
we're on pages two two four so this is
regulation and planning district
development so I'll just work through
these pages
um two two four
two two five
yep
yeah
you might just want to remove one of the
ends yeah the second one preferably
right
um
two two six
two two seven
two two eight
we're now into civil defense so that's
still Tracy so thanks thanks Trevor for
yours
I don't think there's anything else you
need to cover there so thank you very
much
um they were into people uh or Property
Management so who's dealing with that
part
yes yes
well look why don't we just go through
it and if we need staff for a quick
thanks Tracy appreciate thank you
we're trying to think of them now
they're all coming now
okay
um so first one is uh 230
and that's the point I was making
earlier about Madeleine around the
social housing working party if we can
just add that in there
uh
yes sorry Wendy he's got um
elderly housing so are we doing social
housing and elderly housing or social
well
it's in the it's it's regarded as social
I think in bracket support of all no
it's not affordable no it's not the
other teams but anyway the working party
is the appropriate place for it to be
considered yeah it does yep
um but yes we'll work on that perhaps
work on that wording um that's there in
the recommendation
okay
um two three one
it's Communications now two three two
and it's it's very
analytical rather than
communication space I just suggest that
they make it more a little bit more
user-friendly
is under the
um five two twos asking about the
promoting it's more about promotion but
about the website as such it's kind of
um particularly about making sure we
include places and equipments and things
like that so the answer really is
talking about making a website better
but the the what they're actually asking
is for us to promote
so it's a promotions question
okay
we'll note that thank you guess about it
uh two three three
two three four
two three it goes on to two three five
you can stay there Jeff because these
are yours finance and business support
why don't we deal with the governance
report wow
we're here you're okay with it it's
pretty straightforward that one
if you want to that's um
6.19333 to 335. you basically in short
because of the health reforms it's gone
into one entity there's no election and
so we used to make 75 000 every three
years comes as a reimbursement so we're
going to write that off over three three
years 25 000 per year
cool thank you
summer so any questions you're prepared
to move count strickenson second dead
Council Barnett
any discussion
I'll put the recommendation all those in
favor
country Carriage
um
do you want to deal with the carryovers
now Jeff 6.2 you okay with that yeah
basically there's a list of carryovers
there that have been collated from the
staff
um and it makes a difference of 0.1
percent uh you think it'd be a lot
higher but not of worse not all of it is
loan funded a lot of it comes from
subsidies
um from nzta
um
and other contributions that come in
DC's that fund the capital works so
that's why it's sitting at 0.1 percent
and she drops the rates because you
haven't got the loan sitting there that
you're paying for on the one on one July
okay thanks Chief any questions
some of you to move the recommendation
Council Blackie
Council Council Brian
any discussion all those in favor all
right contrary to clear that carried so
if we just go back to the White Pages or
to our book
so we're at 236.
237 I wondered if we should could we
could mention and hear we talk about the
mahitahi but we also have the roonana
liaison group as well if we're just dead
there then to the wedding
um
uh
two three h
uh 239
yeah so we can add that in there
yep really good so let's let's put that
in there that we're going to have the
and the weeding that we have asked
requested a review of discretion
refunding
yeah not that one has just prompted
there was a couple of people who
submitted on the Heritage Fund in in the
response to them it would be good to add
the um
yeah yeah hello can you pick it up
the Heritage yeah yeah so we just need
to pick that up what we've what we've
actually resolved today
additional funding to it then we're
going to open the contestable for
um open the fund for um
open the contestable fund sorry that
says
starting to find myself being
contestable right
um 240 again that's yeah that's been
that just that ringer Ashley community
board will just need to pick up what the
council resolved there
um two four one
two four two
two four three
two four four
and we could actually update that
wording there because we have agreed on
the time frame as post three Waters
review but into next year we were
talking about having that so
if we could just update that wording in
the bottom there
with all loads of the resource that
we've now put in there's that worth
mentioning that because he has resourced
the three Waters review to all these
people that have updated it as well yep
that was um
Central rural drainage Advisory Group
so we picked picked up that point in
there
okay uh so we're at 245 now
246.
yes you just quickly did anyone else top
of the page notice the irony of a
organization that's 200 million dollars
in deficit telling us how to run our
finances
yes yes
and we'll need to pick up the overall
rates increases because they're
different than what we've got and the
reasons there so
um
or in the recommendations back so it's
247 that's that answer
yeah
yeah we've run out of them terrible
all right let's just
um do a wash up
um make sure we've got everything dealt
with
uh
it's a seven we've already considered
the submissions
we don't need another recommendation or
any further resolution because we've
considered all those
and it means that them as needed so I've
got no questions understanding orders no
agent General business we've considered
the meter and with the public excluded
just double check we have
we've already done that
was right does it start
yes sorry
oh yes that's probably right actually
okay well it's for the purposes of
completeness
um final resolution that the staff
recommendations on
the staff recommendations on submissions
and recommended responses to submitters
be confirmed except where otherwise
amended but we covered this at the start
um because that recommendation at the
start actually covered that consider all
all public submissions receive
proformination decisions will be fine ah
right yes we do need that
yeah it's fine because also it
authorized the mayor and chief executive
to let's just say that in
so I'm happy to move
at staff recommendations on submissions
and recommended responses to submitters
be confirmed except where otherwise
amended and just for the purposes of
completeness authorize the mere and
chief executive to approve any editorial
amendments in the final versions of the
responses to submitters have I hit some
of bet II second can I just this has
been a really really good day we've made
really good progress and that is due to
the fact of the work that our staff have
put in which has been extraordinary it's
been a huge amount of work going to
acknowledge all our staff that have been
involved in it so if the chief executive
could please pass our thanks on to all
the staff that have been involved in
this process that would be appreciated
and also to all our governance staff
that have supported us today there's a
number of
um yeah and as well the catering to make
sure we're well looked after it'll be a
record actually getting through a
long-term plan that they time to thank
you all for helping make that possible
today because I think it's been held in
really good spirits so thank you so I
have pleasure in moving there do you
wish to speak just very quickly I just I
just want to reiterate over here for
some time had some concern around our
meetings and times and what we've done
and I just want to remind people that
you've just added seven reports to uh to
what we've done today on top of the
workload of our staff and most of those
are in the area in which we didn't
re-resource we did approve resources to
three Waters and also to the gcp but
that's not where we requested reports
from and and I think we all need to be
very aware of the Walk of the workload
of our staff and what is happening there
so I think we need to be really careful
we've brought from we've also brought
forward one project on top of that which
also adds to them and we have
we've also brought the staff have also
brought forward under their
recommendation I might add three
projects and and we're traveling at 90
success rate at the moment of getting
things done I'm just really really
conscious in it and through this process
want to make it really aware that
the reports that we're requesting and
I'm not saying that they're not
necessary because we wouldn't request
them if they were but we really need to
keep in mind about the workload of our
staff and what reports in the future
that we are requesting and what we're
asking them to do because they really
are stretched as it is at the moment and
I include myself in that I am not
talking about anyone in particular I'm
talking about collectively but look also
to you Mr Mia thank you for the cheering
that you have done it's um that's been
really good you've pushed it through and
um I think it's been well worthwhile so
thank you thank you and if you're the
speakers counts Savannah thank you just
very quickly I totally endorse the
comments that councilor Atkinson has
made but I also have utmost face on our
CE to bring to our attention if there is
any need for additional staff resource
if we are these matters are important
they came from our community they came
from submitters so we need to listen we
need to answer and if we don't have the
answers today we need to find them going
forward over the next few years we know
everything can't be done overnight we
know there's a lot of pressure but I I
would hope and trust that the great
relationship we've got with staff and
our chief executive that they will be
confident to bring anything back if they
need additional resource to do things
that our community has asked of us
okay it counts let's do it
um I do agree I mean I understand what
um what counselor Atkinson's saying and
also what um councilor Burnett is saying
and I'm aware that you know within
within three Waters there's two managers
that aren't um his jobs haven't been um
been filled and in fact that in itself
um puts pressure on on others but I mean
we are we have gone out with one of the
lowest if not the lowest rate increases
in the country
and I just I question and and while
that's wonderful you know and we can we
can tell our residents that
but in fact I I think we make a rod for
our back in the sense that there are
projects out there that we we don't come
up to speed with and I'll and in the
environmental space in biodiversity
State base we are behind the eight ball
and I am well aware that we've got you
know very scant numbers of Staff in
there that are enormous enormously
pressed and feel
um reluctant to come and say that the
workload is huge and we've got to do
this thing there and there's a point
where in fact it works against the
health of and well-being of this
community and when I'm talking about
health and well-being of community I'm
talking about
the holistic look at the environment the
builtscape and and the people that are
there so I do want to I don't want to
really have the
um I guess be in the position of being
the lowest in in New Zealand for a rate
rise because I just don't think that is
sustainable at all and there is valid
and good work that needs to be done and
we are cutting our community short by
not understanding that and as I say
particularly in the environmental space
so I would like to see myself that there
is another percent or more and I'm I the
door is open for me to to see that we in
fact next time around in the annual plan
that we do address some of these
projects that we have
voluntarily curtailed and I mean we
understand why we've done that but to my
my mind that is short term and we
shouldn't get seduced by going out there
and being the lowest because in fact it
means that we do not really deliver to
the wider health and well-being of this
community and I just want to say that at
the end of this which has been an
excellent exercise today and I do
complement the staff on its flowed well
the chairmanship's been good and as you
see I eat Mr near the collegiality
around the table has been excellent so
well done but I don't want to hold the
banner up for continuing to be the
lowest rate rise in New Zealand because
I don't think that delivers to our
community
thank you okay any further speakers
just arrived reply briefly there's going
to be a workshop in June uh with with
staff and that's where we'll have an
opportunity to have a very Frank
discussion around our workload and sorry
the staff's workload at Versa and
elected members in that space and look
we we're not in a position where we can
deliver absolutely everything councilor
Atkinson's right we have requested
reports that's in putting things into
process actually so whilst there are
reports requested I would hope Jim that
the team don't take that as an immediate
request that's something to be to be
worked on over time it's not something
that has to be done now they're a matter
to be put into the work stream for
consideration and that meters this
counts the banner rightly observed have
have come from our community
um I don't share the view that we had an
extra one percent
um but we do have to be mindful of the
preachers that our staff are under and
our organizations under and that comes
to us managing the workload but also
bear in mind that we have a community
that's also hoosing I don't want to go
out there crowing that we've got the
lowest rate increase by any stretch the
imagination but to show that we have
demonstrated Prudence to our community
because that is something that they do
appreciate that we're doing unlike
colleagues down the road that frankly
haven't and I don't want to be in that
situation ever here so yes we've added
some more we're up to what 4.3 now but
we've added in the things that we felt
are needed at this time but it's always
a rebalancing every time and we'll be
into just as soon as we finish the
long-term claim we're into consideration
of the annual plan so it's um it starts
again doesn't it team so but there's a
lot of work to be done from there within
the organization of getting the
responses sorted and getting those out
so to all the staff that are taking
their part in that thank you for the
work that you'll be doing but again
appreciate the work colleagues it's been
a good it's been a good day and a good
lead up to this exercise I think it's
probably one of the best I've been
involved in my time here at Council so
thank you
all right with that sorry did you ever
need something jump
um just just one thing on the resources
um I've been warming the organization up
to a conversation around that
um basically we've got 250 days all of
us to work for you and the community
the critical thing is that we we know
what's an a b and a c job with those 250
days linked to council priorities so
um I've got some ideas of how we can do
that
um because you know it's that it and
it's being realistic because if we've we
can't just keep loading up we get to a
point where we'll burn people out so
it's finding that sweet spot where we
know what the important jobs are and the
other ones and maybe we never get to the
Sea jobs for three years or so be it but
if we don't have some sense of what that
looks like then you know it's going to
be hard for us to be honest with you
about resourcing but most people will
come into Marvel and say I need more
resource but they can't really tell me
why and how many hours they're spinning
on different things so let's just say
I've I've started this conversation at a
high level I'm wanting people through
this next round of the PDP thing just
taking the current format to tell me
what their priorities are and then to
match it from there so yeah we are aware
of that there's a risk and yeah we've
also got the uncertainty of these
reforms and we don't want to lose key
staff so
there's two other things that I'd like
to well not like to and we're going to
get done this next few months is you
know critical Talent who are they and
what do we need to do to develop them
and keep them and for key positions or
all positions really what's our
succession plan look like so because if
we don't grow some we're going to do
that consciously we're just going to
poach and you know and that's not really
sustainable because all you're doing is
checking up salaries and you're not
growing the pool so those conversations
have already started with the executive
team and with some of my meeting with
various groups I've in a wee online
video I've started introducing some of
the sort of very high level
all right everyone well it's worth it um
our next meetings to be held 2 30 on
Tuesday the well for this uh it's
actually Tuesday we next week but
they're on the 22nd of June for the
purpose of adopting the long-term plan
thanks everyone have a good evening
happy birthday again Kirsten hope you
enjoy that time with your family
to clear the meeting close
foreign